Four,
three,
two,
one.
Yes.
Mick West.
We are alive finally.
Are you ready?
I am ready.
Let's do it.
Until you're getting a lot of heat
online from all these.
It's all the flat earth people and the
chem trail people.
Those are the people that are mad at you
the most.
That's my specialty.
Chem trails and flutter.
Yeah.
Well that's.
I ask people.
This is hilarious.
I asked people online,
I said,
I'm mick west from Medibank is going to
be here.
What would you like me to debunk?
And one of the first ones was chem
trails because you cannot debunk it.
It's real Dun Dun,
Duh.
I would do.
I would say this to anybody who thinks
that that has got to be the most
ineffective government program of all
time.
Like he asked people what they're doing
things in the sky and the number one
thing they'll say is like weather
control.
Weather controls one.
Well they don't have any fucking control
of the weather because if they did
they'd make it rain all over Santa
Barbara and stop these fires.
Yeah,
I mean there's hundreds of millions of
dollars where the damage going on right
now,
there's a fire that's bigger than the
city of Washington DC.
They think they're making those bias.
I think that that's part of the
conspiracy.
Anything that happens is.
Oh,
as part of the conspiracy,
what do you think it is?
Like what is,
what is it with conspiracies,
like what,
why are they so attractive to people?
There's something going on with people,
right?
Yeah.
I think,
yeah,
I've been looking into this a lot and
you have,
especially since you're a government
show.
Well,
I'm doing research with a book on
writing called escaping the rabbit hole
and it's about how people get into the
rabbit hole and how people get out of
the rabbit hole.
So the whole thing is about the rabbit
hole,
which is something basically people get
sucked into and I think people do a lot
of research into the reasons behind
people getting into conspiracy theories
like the psychological reasons and they
uh,
personality reasons and things like
that.
But I think most conspiracy theorists
are just regular people.
They're just ordinary people who get
sucked into something.
And why do you think that is?
Just from talking to them,
they tell me like the origin stories,
the origin stories essentially,
and they tell me what happened to them
when they got into conspiracy theories
and it nearly always starts with looking
at some video.
I now nowadays with them looking at some
video and then they just get sucked in.
Yeah.
And then they start looking at another
video and another video and another
video and facebook and youtube is
feeding them these videos because once
you start going down that road,
you just can't,
you can't change your trajectory.
It's hard to treat in Youtube,
uh,
since they instigated this,
autoplay thing or instituted this
autoplay thing or the next video plays
immediately and they're all related.
I think that's definitely been a thing
with people.
And also like the suggestions on right
hand side if you're watching one video
in particular subject.
Yeah.
Within some experiments with that set up
like a completely blank youtube account.
And I would just go in there and typing
one thing like con trials and of course
when you look at trails on youtube,
like half the videos,
you're going to get it going to be
Kentrell videos.
And so if the first video you click on
is the chem trail video,
then that just sets you down that road.
Well,
I remember this was in the days,
I think before youtube,
this is in the days when maybe youtube
was around,
but it just wasn't that popular.
I remember me and my friend Eddie,
we're high as fuck and we're talking to
my neighbor and there was some plane
that was flying over and we were
wondering why the clouds coming from
behind this plane's stood so long.
And so I asked him,
I said,
this neighbor,
I used to call them bling,
bling,
bling was incapable of talk about
anything other than objects.
Like all we talk about that as a nice
car.
It's got a new car.
Would you get there?
Watch.
That was blank,
blank.
All bling bling wanted to talk about is
like material possessions.
So.
So he,
he knows were parked uh,
in front of his.
I was saying hi to them and I said,
hey man,
do you remember clouds?
Look,
stick it around and this guy that long.
And he was like,
um,
no,
I don't know.
Is that a new truck?
And like,
I just remember how ironic it was
because I had told Eddie about blink,
blink,
you know,
this is all this guy cares about and
wants to talk about.
And then he did that while we're out
there.
But I remember thinking,
man,
how weird would it be if all of a sudden
clouds from jet engines started
appearing and it just appeared right
before our eyes and we had noticed it,
but I wasn't sold.
It didn't make any sense to me because
my thought on it was the amount of
people that had to be involved.
You're talking about all these different
airplanes get all these people to keep
their mouth shut.
These are their pilots,
right?
So they're not making shit tons of money
and they live here too.
That's the other thing,
like if there's actually spraying
something in the sky,
they live here too.
Like what are they spraying themselves?
Well the theory now is the,
it's basically the power elite in the
country is doing these chem trails as it
kinda latched last ditch attempt to
maintain power before the entire world
collapses into chaos.
So they think it's kind of like a
desperate situation.
A power grab.
Exactly.
It's,
it's the,
the hanging on to have that kind of last
hurrah.
I really,
they feel like the end of the world is
nigh,
like,
you know this about to put this
environmental disaster and the chem
trails.
So the only thing that is holding
everything together,
that's the thing that you get if you go
to like,
you know,
gun geoengineering,
watch Dane Wigington Guy,
he,
he's basically a,
an apocalyptic prophet now.
He's basically preaching about how
everything is going to end soon.
And the,
the chem trails of the only thing that's
stopping it,
but also making it worse.
So he's kind of saying like,
you know,
the controls are helping,
but we got to stop them.
Otherwise,
it'll make it even worse,
but we're pretty much all going to die
either way because a lot of money and
we're going to die.
There's a lot of people that love that,
that that trope is just like something
that gets carted out constantly
throughout history because it's true.
You are going to die.
It's like,
when are you going to die?
You don't know.
So because you don't know.
You're freaking out.
Like,
is it going to be a car accident?
Is he going to be a fire?
Is going to be an earthquake,
is going to be a slow aging death,
or is it going to be the chem trails?
Yeah.
I think that type of thing,
like fear of dying is one of those
fundamental things that every human is
Khalid wide with certain things that
they,
that happens in the brain without them
thinking about and fear of dying and
fear of other things,
fear of loss,
fear of wolves or whatever.
Something that's hardwired.
And that's the type of thing that leads
to different types of thinking that,
uh,
you know,
you ended up being a conspiracy
theorists in part because your brain is
wired that way.
You had a great quote about chem trails
when we did that television show
together.
You said Chem trails are like the
training wheels for conspiracy theorists
because they're like,
they're,
they're right above your head and you're
just like,
you see them right there for people.
Don't understand why jets produce
clouds.
Please explain that because it's very
simple.
It is very simple.
A jet engines have water.
I have water in their exhaust,
it can look at a car on a cold day and
you see the exhaust coming out of the
tailpipe.
You'll see like a cloud condensation
sometimes and you'll see some water
coming out.
And when they,
the exact same thing happens with jet
engines.
Uh,
and when that exhaust hits,
the colder it condenses,
it freezes,
it makes a cloud.
And Con controls are essentially,
clouds are exactly the same basically as
a regular service cloud.
And it's dependent upon the amount of
moisture in the atmosphere.
And you can actually monitor it online.
NASA actually has a website that will
show you,
and I believe it's set up for pilots,
right?
Is that what the air traffic people are
actually has a contrail forecasting side
isn't really for pilots or anything.
It's just part of the country research.
Uh,
but yeah,
they have a site where it will predict
like,
well controls.
They're going to baby.
You can do it yourself.
You just go to look up the relative
humidity at a certain altitude.
There's lots of different sites you can
go to.
I've got a whole bunch of them listed on
Medibank and just like the clouds very
in the sky,
all the amount of moisture various as
well,
which is one of the reasons why you will
see a jet pass through one area and
you'll see a contrail.
And then it almost looks like they shut
the contrail jets off and then you see
it pick up maybe a couple hundred yards
later.
And that's say like a cloud.
It's really exactly the same as the
cloud.
If you look at any picture of a cloudy
day and then just remove all the clouds,
but they're still there as an invisible
clouds.
Then when the plane comes along,
it's almost like the plane is this magic
pen revealing these invisible clouds
because all the cloud is a region of the
sky where the humidity is above a
certain level.
So you know,
the,
the
humidity's pretty patchy across the sky
cause like there's a cloud here and
right next to it there's no cloud.
So where the cloud is,
it's high humidity where the cloud
isn't,
is Loki meditate.
But if both of those were just lowered
like 10 percent,
then you get no clouds at all than a
plane comes along.
She erases the humidity in the cloud
area,
ended the non-cloud area.
But this area,
because it was a bit higher,
uh,
you get a trail forming in this area,
getting a trail forming.
So it's exactly the same as invisible
clouds.
Yeah.
And for people that are watching it and
you're looking up,
you think they're spraying something if
you're conspiracy minded.
And because of a lot of the videos that
are out there in particular to that were
recommended to me are what in the hell
have they sprang?
Right.
So I got to meet with that guy that made
those documentaries and a right away I
knew something was wrong.
Like he's either on adderall or
something.
He's just like real,
real edgy and speed it up.
And just an odd guy,
which is like a lot of people that are
conspiracy really conspiratorially
minded.
They seem to be like very.
They're nervous and agitated.
And,
and when we went over like why he thinks
one of the things that he was talking
about was the soil samples and water
samples and that they've detected all
this aluminum and barium in water and
particularly aluminum.
And he's showing me all these results
that he had.
But even on the very results that he
showed me,
it said sludge.
Like he had sent them out for testing.
And I said,
well,
what did you send in his?
He goes,
well,
I sent some water from these ponds.
And I said,
but it says sludge on your testing.
And he said,
nobody was water.
I go,
okay,
but the lab said it sludge.
I go,
what is sludge?
She goes,
well,
I don't know what sludge is exactly.
I go,
well,
let's look.
Sludge is a combination of water and
dirt.
Okay,
so you sent water and dirt.
So do you know that aluminum is one of
the most common metals on earth.
And you could basically scoop up a patch
of dirt pretty much anywhere and find a
bunch of aluminum in it.
It's really,
really common in trace amounts.
I go,
so what you did is you tested dirt and
it tested positive for being dirt
musically.
That's exactly what it is.
And the guy was kind of freaking out.
I'm like,
how did you,
how did you not put this together
yourself?
Like if you're the guy who's making this
video and you're trying to find a reason
why,
you could know some facts that you could
throw at people,
we could say,
hey look,
the government is definitely spraying
things in the sky.
They're spraying them aluminum.
Look,
we found the aluminum and we founded in
the water.
It's in your water supply.
It's going to get in your body,
it's going to poison you.
Look,
we found in the water,
how did it,
how the fuck did he not look at it
himself is what I was thinking and meet
when me and him were having this
conversation,
I realized like you have these people
that go down,
they're not open minded in regards to
these subjects.
They go down a very narrow road and that
road is,
the government is doing something to me.
I need to find
out what it is.
Yeah.
And they're really motivated to actually
find evidence.
Yes.
So that trying to find something and you
know,
actually trying to find an alternative
explanation isn't really that attracted
to them.
So they find aluminum in the water or in
the soil or whatever.
And then they glom onto that as being
evidence of geoengineering and that's
great for them because they can just
find loads and loads of samples of soil
and that's something that gets repeated
online.
That very fact over and over again,
the aluminum that they found in the
water,
it's one of the core tenants is like one
of the pillars of the chem trail thing.
There's a,
there's a,
there's like four or five different
things,
like in every conspiracy theory,
there are these core beliefs that,
uh,
the 99 percent of the people who believe
in the theory,
one core belief is that you work for the
government.
Yeah.
That is a core belief.
Make,
is a retired video game creator.
You could find that out.
Made Video Games,
right?
Tony Hawk.
Yeah.
Made a shit ton of money and decided to,
uh,
to debunk dorks.
Yeah,
I didn't.
It didn't start out and I wouldn't refer
to them as Dorks,
but I'm saying they're dorks.
Yeah.
Dorks,
if they don't believe this is the
problem.
You're not a Dork.
If you fall for something,
you're a Dork.
you don't believe the science that shows
that it's impossible,
but it's not real.
But if you were spraying aluminum in the
sky,
folks,
it would look like aluminum.
You dummy,
it wouldn't look like a cloud.
It wouldn't dissipate.
It would look like a thin missed
essentially.
Yeah,
and metal is not.
It's heavier than fucking air and vapor.
It's not.
It's not going to just sit up there like
that.
It would.
It would be a very different experience.
It has slowly settled to the ground and
wouldn't look like a cloud and there's
no reason to do it.
There's no benefit whatsoever.
There's no scientific evidence ever
uncovered ever that there's any benefit
for anybody of sprang aluminum over
people.
It's just,
it's just,
it's a waste of aluma thing.
Even with the,
the whole geoengineering field,
there's really no solid evidence that it
will work and we don't know what the
side effects will be.
We don't know how much we're going to.
We would need to spray and we don't
know,
like,
uh,
you know,
if,
if you know,
when we stopped doing it will bounce
back in a terrible way and it'd be a big
disaster.
Well,
that's an interesting thing because one
of the reasons why I'm contrary hills
are interesting to study is because they
actually do have an effect on the
temperature of the earth and this is
something that we found out after nine
slash 11 when September 11th happened in
2001,
it was the,
the,
the big disaster.
There was a shutdown on all flights in
the United States.
And when they did that,
the temperature changed.
Yeah,
because is clouds literally do provide
like a cover and it is,
it does,
do they act as an insulator or an
escalator?
Uh,
they essentially act as an insulator.
They block a radiation incoming
radiation during the day
and they block outgoing radiation at
night.
But the net effect is that they actually
block more outgoing radiation than they
do incoming radiation.
So if planes didn't fly at night than
you would,
you would cool the earth down a,
you'd have to stop flying quite a bit
before nighttime.
So if all the flights in the world were
between like a 5:00
AM and 5:00
PM local time,
then you could actually call the world
down by just not having any flights at
night because if the night flights that
have this really big kind of blanketing
effect that stopped being outgoing,
radiation.
So the night of flights actually heat
the world up.
Yes they do.
They act like a,
like a blanket,
uh,
you know how it's,
it's warmer on a well in a cloudy day.
Like he doesn't get as cold at night,
you know,
does it get really cold at night because
there's nothing over them.
They tend to have any,
any cover one.
It's one of the reasons,
but yeah,
they,
the controls will actually a warm the
planet because the,
the amount of outgoing radiation they
block is just way high.
I just go with the wave lengths and the
size of the particles.
That one.
So that,
that's something to be concerned about,
that that's something that people are
legitimately monitoring.
Um,
when people need to understand is just
because you feel like when you look up
in the sky and see this crisscross
patterns that they're spraying,
you know,
one's spraying.
This is just a natural reaction to jet
engines and condensation in the
atmosphere and the heat and the moisture
of the jet engine.
That's all it is.
There it,
they are actually talking about a way of
using controls for a kind of Geo
engineering and this is something that
people often get confused about because
you see these two words together,
controls and engineering and they think,
oh,
that's chem trails,
but what they're trying to do is use air
traffic control and computers and
weather forecasting to make it so the
planes don't fly through the contrail
forming areas when they would make
controls at night.
I'm making.
So they do fly route contrary or forming
areas what it might make some trials
during the day.
So this is a conversation they're having
or something that's actually being.
It's not something that they've actually
done something that they can research
fairly easily.
So if they were considering trying to
heat up the atmosphere or heat up the
earth at night,
they would just fly over these moisture
rich areas and if they weren't,
they would avoid them.
Yeah.
The goal obviously is to combat climate
change,
global warming and cooling down so that
a relatively cheap way of doing that to
a degree is to have these planes be
controlled by computers and it could
increase his fuel costs,
but the airline by about two or three
percent because they had to make very
deviations sometimes in height and
sometimes indirection,
but it could actually have a significant
effect on the earth climate if we had
the entire world,
airline fleets all in this program where
they would fly,
making controls where they were needed
and not making contracts where they were
not needed
and how exactly they're monitoring the
moisture content of the atmosphere.
Like what are they to do that
satellites.
Yeah,
it's a combination of things.
Uh,
the,
the youth sounding balloons,
which are these red weather balloons
basically,
which got mistaken for Ufo is quite a
lot.
And they use satellites and they use a
planes a sensing the environment when
they're flying through it and they use
all these inputs and it goes into a big
computer model,
which basically predicts where the,
uh,
what the,
humidity will be at any particular point
is basically a big weather forecast.
But the upper atmosphere
now jamie,
Google Cei a admits Geo engineering
because this is one that the cabot trail
believers constantly bring up.
It was a conversation that I'm some guy
in the CIA had at some meeting where
they were discussing potential future
ways,
uh,
to use geo engineering.
Like,
let's play with this.
Guys has CIA director,
John Brennan,
go ahead,
often referred to collectively as Geo
engineering that potentially could help
reverse the warming effects of global
climate change.
One that has gained my personal
attention is stratospheric aerosol
injection or Sai,
a method of seeding the stratosphere
with particles that can help reflect the
sun's heat.
And much the same way that volcanic
eruptions do in Sai program could limit
global temperature increases,
reducing some risks associated with
higher temperatures and providing the
wires that are freaking out.
Keep changing back to to youtube glitch.
I have to refresh the page and I didn't
want to restart.
This guy had epilepsy?
Yeah,
spheric.
Eris.
Hold on.
Go ahead and just take it from where he
left it here.
What else?
He has to say?
Injection or s a I.
A method of seeding the stratosphere
with particles that can help reflect the
sun's heat in much the same way that
volcanic eruptions do.
An Sai program could limit global
temperature increases,
reducing some risks associated with
higher temperatures and providing the
world economy additional time to
transition from fossil fuels.
This process is also relatively
inexpensive.
The National Research Research Council
estimates that are fully deployed.
Sai Program would cost about
$10,000,000,000
yearly as promising as it may be moving
forward on sai would also raise a number
of challenges for our government and for
the international community.
On the technical side,
greenhouse gas emission reductions would
still have to accompany sai to address
other climate change effects such as
ocean acidification,
because sai alone would not remove
greenhouse gases from the atmosphere on
the geopolitical side,
their technologies potential to alter
weather patterns and benefit certain
regions of the world at the expense of
other regions could trigger sharp
opposition by some nations others might
seize on SSI benefits and back away from
their commitment to carbon dioxide.
And as with other breakthrough
technologies,
global norms and standards are lacking
to guide the deployment and
implementation of Sai and otherwise.
Cool.
We get it.
So this guy is talking about an idea of
spraying things in the atmosphere to do
something.
Yeah.
He's talking about geoengineering
spraying stuff from playing was talking
about.
He's talking about reflective particles,
right?
Isn't it?
Yeah.
The spray sulfur dioxide,
which isn't exactly a reflective
protocol,
but it acts as a nucleus for a
parameter.
Speyer clouds and things like that.
It's basically,
like you said,
the same thing.
A volcano does what a volcano erupt.
It spews a whole bunch of sulfur dioxide
and various other things into the upper
atmosphere and that creates hayes
basically,
which,
which blocks the incoming radiation and
cools things down.
Every time a big volcano goes off,
you see a little dip in the earth's
temperature because of this,
this blocking effect that and so the
theory is that you could do something
similar and you could do it by spreading
things out of planes,
but yeah,
he's talking about things that we might
do in the future.
You see every,
every year he uses the future tense,
like we could do this in mind.
They may do this,
the effects might be this,
and he's talking about the possible
geopolitical impacts of it,
which are very significant,
like if one country is going to be
spraying something that would cause the
say the monsoons to double in intensity
or to have and intensity in India.
That could cause the deaths of millions
of people from famine and flooding and
this is what people think has happened
with the big hurricanes in the United
States.
They do think that there's no evidence
of that actually happening.
At the pattern of hurricanes is pretty
much the same as it's been for a long
time.
When you look at the statistical
variations,
there's,
you know,
maybe a bit more intense because the
oceans are a bit warmer where it's not
a,
you know,
people think that hurricanes have been
steered a harp.
Yeah,
through harp,
but that doesn't make any sense,
but there is,
there are ways that do make sense which
are a cloud seeding.
Like if you do lots of seeding of the
hurricane on one side you could perhaps
reduce the amount of humidity and
moisture on that side and so it will
kind of turn a little bit more and move
over to one side.
So there are ways that you might work.
And they did actually experiment with
this.
I think back in the seventies or so,
there was one experiment where they
tried seeding a hurricane,
but he ended up going somewhere else
other than where the were they intended
and it destroyed a whole bunch of
houses.
The problem with having a video like
this is that this guy is admitting that
they have looked into potentially spring
things.
No one has ever denied that.
We've been,
we've been looking into geo engineering
for decades.
It's been proposed like in,
in,
in some sense
we're over 100 years,
the other since the seventies.
The other problem is he cave that.
He gave it a initials as a Pi.
That's a problem.
People love initials.
They love it.
That's super exciting.
Not even really well.
Most people use the srm,
which is,
uh,
the solar radiation management.
Ah,
that's a good one too.
Yeah,
I saw as a CIA dea.
It's okay.
Sounds good.
That sounds.
Sounds more scary than Dziedzic aerosol
injection.
Um,
but they would have to be studies and
has to be.
There are,
there are lots of studies going on right
now.
There are people are studying
geoengineering.
There's actually lots of people who
specialize in Geo engineering.
While I was going to say is studies
would have to be available for people to
understand,
but nobody wants to do that.
Nobody wants to go in and you wanted to
look up and see the thing behind the jet
and go.
They started it.
They're spraying this patchwork.
Look,
this haze all over us.
Which does happen,
you can have a clear sky and you have
the right conditions in a bunch of jets
fly over and all the sudden it's very
hazy.
It does,
it does.
And that's the type of thing that's
being reported since the Second World
War or even even earlier,
either first contract that we're
spreading out into clouds.
We reported in like the 19 twenties.
Yeah,
well I took some of these photos and I
put them up.
I think the last time we had this
conversation where you could see them
from World War II,
you can see these jets and they see the
contract falls behind the jets and the.
But some people.
That's the other thing is con trails,
uh,
dissipate.
But chem trail stay.
Well that's not.
You misunderstand what happens.
The contrail stay.
If there's more moisture,
the,
if the conditions are correct,
they stay.
And if the conditions are barely enough
to make a contrary to dissipate fairly
rapidly with that thing,
they kind of use circular logic.
And if I ask them,
why do you think that controls a
dissipate in Kentrell stay and say,
because I can see it,
if you look up,
you look at the chem trails and the
staging and the country also dissipating
because of how do you know which is
which?
Well,
the country also the ones that
dissipate.
Yeah.
So they don't have any basis for that
belief.
And you know,
the one thing I do,
which you've probably seen is that video
where I go through all my old books on,
on the weather and I look up in each one
of them,
the section on contract and I read the
bit in a contrail processed per hour,
sometimes control,
sometimes spread out to cover the sky
contrary last a long time.
And I go back from these books from the
1998 all the way back to the 19 fifties.
And I've got books in the 19 forties.
And if you show people the actual books
is a really powerful way of getting
through to them because they just
assumed that controls campuses.
Right?
And they've assumed that this is a
recent phenomenon because they don't
remember it clearly weren't paying
attention what the people don't notice
them until you're 90 percent of the
people don't notice Cantrell's until
they hear about the chem trail.
Conspiracy theory.
A lot of people,
they will hear about it.
And then the day they will go
outside and look at the sky.
And then that's the first time that ever
notice these controls.
Even the people that are like the high
ups in the,
uh,
in the,
in the country movement,
they only notice them when they hear
about the theory.
There's a guy,
um,
I can't remember his name now,
but he lived in San Diego and he,
he never noticed them until like 2014.
And he lived there all his life.
And now he's publishing scientific
papers.
Uh,
Jay Marvin Herndon is his name.
He's publishing these scientific papers
about how the sprain slash like the
waste products of burning coal and power
stations.
The spray that in the upper atmosphere.
He's actually got like three or four
papers published in these kind of pay to
publish a scientific journals.
And that's kind of becoming a bit of a
problem.
I like this,
this thing with Brennan,
the CIA guy.
People bring that up all the time,
all the time,
all the time.
And you just have to explain it to them.
Again,
I don't know what he's talking about.
The future use.
And then this guy
talking about possible solutions for.
For global warming.
Yeah.
Now the problem with it is when he's
talking about possible solutions and
then people look up and they see these
actual clouds that are created by jets.
They assumed this has already begun at
the government would not tell us about
it because they don't understand the
difference between contrary and with
this stuff would look like.
Yeah.
And just the fact that contract look
like this,
they,
they heard the contrail shouldn't
persist.
Well what's another thing that drove me
crazy?
He's like,
if you really want to worry about health
consequences of these things that you
see in the sky,
there's a reality to it.
The reality is they're burning jet fuel
and all the people that live around the
airports get sick.
Like it's.
There's,
there's high levels of respiratory
illness that are associated with living
within a certain distance of airplanes
or airports.
If you're in a congested hub like lax,
don't buy a house like a block away.
It's not good for your health.
They're burning jet fuel that's going to
get in the air pollution pollution from
cars.
Yeah,
it's even more intense because you're
having thousands and thousands of giant
planes.
[inaudible] even less smoke Santa
Monica,
they have problems with that.
If you look at the houses just at the
end of Santa Monica runway,
which is right next to the end of the
runway disease houses that did tests
with various metal particulars and stuff
and the ones right by the end of the
runway,
you know,
they get to get pollution.
Of course.
It's very real problems.
That's the real problem.
Yeah,
and that's a real one.
Now imagine if that was something that
the government was engineering,
that they really were engineering
spraying things to give people
respiratory illness so that the hospital
industry could profit and whatever the
reason was.
Right.
That would be,
you know,
something that people could be concerned
with.
Like,
look,
there's a real connection between
airplanes and illnesses,
but it's not spraying in the Scott,
that's not real.
I understand people love these things
and I understand people don't trust the
government.
Those things completely make sense to
me,
but you got to pay attention to what's
real and what's not real,
because as soon as you don't do that,
then all the real stuff that the
government does,
all the real stuff.
The government does like these fucking
roads they're going to build in Alaska
right now through dangerous areas where,
where they have a salmon rivers where
they're gonna they're gonna start doing
mining.
I think.
What is the Pebble Beach?
Is that the.
No,
what is the,
uh,
the,
the big mining issue in Alaska that is
going on right now.
Bristol Bay.
That's it.
Why don't I
pebble in Bristol?
I don't know how I got those two
confused pebble mine.
And that's what it is.
And they want,
they want to do this and it's near a
major salmon area or these salmon river
and they're people that live.
They're terrified that they're going to
do this.
This is a real for profit thing where
they're putting the environment at risk
that's real,
so this is something that people should
be concerned about,
but they're not.
They don't get concerned about those
kinds of things.
You know,
environmentalists do and you know,
big conservationist do,
but the conspiracy theorists don't.
They don't look at that and go,
hey,
here's clear evidence of the government
being in bed with enormous businesses
that stand a profit,
spectacular amounts of money from
risking the environment and risking
these very delicate salmon fisheries.
Yeah.
That type of thing is the exact reason
why I still spend so much time debunking
stuff like conspiracy theories because I
think that so much a of conspiracy
theories,
the results of the effect of conspiracy
theories is distracting people from real
issues.
Some real issue.
Yes.
I agree.
Like if you,
like you say,
with the,
the airplane stuff,
like if people are thinking that
spraying chemicals out of the bed to the
back of the airplanes,
they're just not gonna be worried about
a regular pollution and if they think
that the controlling the climate
already,
they're not going to worry about any
type of global warming.
So let's find a one that we disagree on.
I think you believe the official story
of the JFK assassination.
Do you more or less.
Yeah,
more or less.
My belief in this is this changes over
time.
I think that Lee Harvey Oswald was in on
it.
I think he was a part of it,
but I think there were multiple people
that were in on it.
That's what I believe.
Do you think the multiple shooters?
Yes.
And one of the reasons why I believe
that is because of the formation of the
single bullet theory in the single
bullet theory was formed because the
fact that they had to account for one
bullet that hit the underpass ricocheted
off and put some man in the hospital.
Um,
and that before that they did not have
an explanation for why all of these
bullets bullet holes,
all these wounds were in all these
different people's bodies.
The other reason why I'm inclined to
believe there's a conspiracy was the
fact that they found that bullet on
Connolly's Gurney when they brought him
into the hospital.
It's too convenient.
And the bullet itself is fairly
pristine.
Now,
knowing as much as I know about bullets
from personal experience of hunting,
you can hit anything with the boy.
I pulled a lot of bullets out of
animals.
When you shoot an animal and you hit
bone,
those bullets,
they distort brutally.
I mean,
they don't look like that.
And if they go through to people and hit
all sorts of bone,
that's the bullet that came out of
Connolly's body or connolly's Gurney,
excuse me.
And that's the bullet that they are
attributing to this,
a single bullet theory.
Uh,
if you look at the path of the bullet
that goes through connolly or goes
through Kennedy and then goes through
connelly,
that to me is,
is not unbelievable.
It's not unbelievable.
That one is,
hey,
you've got to look at the other one,
but even that one,
but no,
no.
See what I'm saying.
Even that one is not unbelievable.
It is believable to me because I know
that bullets do strange things when they
hit things
right.
But you've got to combine that with the
fact that the bullet came out fairly
pristine,
which meant it didn't actually go
through a kind of a bouncy path like
that.
It went through a straight path.
This diagram is from a conspiracy
theorist,
but essentially,
yes.
But the thing of the diagrams that will
show the actual path with him,
like,
you know,
they've got them the butts that are on
the same level and you know that Kennedy
was actually sitting here was ella
bullied?
Yes.
So,
um,
see if we can find one that has the
actual seating arrangement or more
accurate seating.
They will.
They will one right there with the red
line and the right hand side.
The one the right hand side.
That's a more accurate.
I'm from above.
From above,
yeah.
There's,
there's also the fact that there was
particles,
there was more metallic particles from
the bullets,
more fragments from the bullet in
Conley's body.
Then we're missing from the bullet.
I do not believe that was the bullet and
I think that that is a very reasonable
assumption.
Well,
you know what you should do.
You should get one of those guns.
Get the same bullets.
Okay.
Some ballistic dummies,
which some bones inside and start
shooting.
They've already done that.
Yeah.
The Penn and teller did that.
Some people have done it and they have
found pretty close to what actually
happened.
No,
they did within within the ground.
no,
no.
Every bullet that hit bone got
distorted.
That's just what happens.
The you shoot those bullets into water
or you shoot those bullets into like
fluff or something like that.
That doesn't have a lot of impact to
slow the bullet down or then you get a
bullet that looks like that.
If you shoot a bullet into bone,
they distort wildly where the bone was.
The last thing that it hit,
but it doesn't matter.
It's still hitting bone,
but he stopped at that point.
Yeah,
but I mean,
didn't it hit bone and in Kennedy's body
as well?
Hm.
Went through his neck.
The odds of it hitting only soft tissue
and it's going to go through his neck
and it came out here that didn't clip
one of his vertebrae or something like
that.
I don't think that's real.
I think also there's a difference
between,
and this is fact from David Lifton's
book best evidence,
which was a book by a,
an accountant to win over,
um,
the Warren Commission report and fennel
is factual inaccuracies and all these
contradictions.
He found that there was a difference in
the autopsy report at Bethesda,
Maryland,
the to naval hospital versus the,
the show what they had reported on the
scene in Dallas.
The first doctors that got ahold of
Kennedy's body in Dallas before they
flew him to Bethesda,
said that the hole in his neck was an
entry wound.
When they got to Maryland,
they changed that to a tracheotomy
whole.
They changed the impact and they said
that it was a.
They said that this was not an impact
from a bullet,
that it was from something else.
Yeah.
Someone said they enlarge the hole.
Insert a trick tube.
Yeah.
Well,
I think.
uh,
there was,
there was also a lot of pressure on
these people to try to wrap this up nice
and tight and say that Lee Harvey Oswald
was the shooter.
There was.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's this big thing about the CIA,
the CIA inventing the FBI.
The FBI will inventing the term
conspiracy theory.
He was a CIA thing.
I think it was A.
Yeah.
And this was a couple of years after the
assassination.
They,
uh,
there was a memo that went out were they
were concerned about all these
conspiracy theories that were coming out
and they used it to them conspiracy
theories and then they,
they said they should try to,
uh,
basically debunk them and make the
people who,
uh,
spread them around look like a
conspiracy theorist.
But basically the theory is that the
term conspiracy theory came from that
particular memo,
that memo that never actually encouraged
people to use the term.
Uh,
but yeah,
there was a huge concern from the CIA
that they would be,
they would lose the trust of the public
if people,
everybody started believing that it was
a conspiracy theory.
At least that's what they said.
I mean maybe there is a conspiracy and
maybe they are just trying to cover it
up.
But
did you see the most recent dump of
information on the Kennedy assassination
that Jack Ruby had stated to people that
before the day of the Kennedy
assassination,
keep an eye out today that's going to be
fireworks.
I didn't say that.
Yeah,
those Jack Ruby who eventually wound up
shooting Lee Harvey Oswald in front of
the police officer.
Yeah,
something like that.
You know,
his dad obviously.
So you couldn't ask him what he actually
meant and things like that take on a
special significance after an event.
True.
Whereas it could be just talking about
it,
like he was going to go visit his ex
wife or something or it was going to go
to the bar or he was looking forward to
shouting at the parade or whatever.
Could have been nothing but people say
things and you know,
after something happens people go back
and they look at everything that
happened and then they say,
well that sounds like something
significant.
Like with the Vegas shooting,
uh,
there was a woman walking around the
crowd in the Vegas shooting saying,
yeah,
you're all going to die.
Basically what some people said,
and this was like half an hour before
the actual shooting itself.
So people take that event and then since
a lot of people did die,
they think that this woman actually knew
what was going to happen and she was
trying to warn people.
Right.
But you also get crazy people wandering
around saying things all the time,
you know,
especially in Vegas.
Yeah.
And the problem with you're all going to
die is that,
that's a common one.
Some guy was yelling that we took
pictures of them when we're in vegas
long before the shooting.
It was a few months ago we were
standing.
No,
we were in a car and he was standing on
the corner and he had a stack of signs.
I put it up on my instagram.
I know I did because there was many,
there was stacks of signs.
He had not just one sign.
We had like a long totem pole of signs
with all these different things and I
was taking photos of it and the guy was
yelling out,
everyone's going to die.
I mean he was yelling it out that you
know God's wrath and all this crazy
religious stuff.
That's a common thing for crazy people
to shout.
Yes.
What they do show.
It's not like this woman was saying
specifically someone is going to shoot
everyone at this concert,
get out of here.
This is a dangerous area.
If she was trying to warn them,
she would have been a bit more specific.
Yes,
very specific.
Right.
If she knew something,
do you see?
Do you find it?
No,
I know I put it up there because we were
mocking it.
Maybe I'll put it on my instagram story
and it went away.
I don't think so though.
I think it's,
it's there from.
I want to say,
I want to say it was at least six months
ago,
but we were mocking this guy because
this guy got a lot of fucking signs,
like one signs on enough.
I go is this is the guy,
this is the reason why twitter only has
140 characters.
Motherfuckers like this.
I,
I remember is like July because there's
like 120 degrees out too,
wasn't it?
Yes.
It was a very hot.
This goofy ass hole had this giant stack
of science.
Um,
so the,
the back to the Kennedy thing,
what do you think happened?
Do you think that Lee Harvey Oswald
probably acted alone?
I think he probably acted alone.
I think the physics of what happened
like is fairly consistent with the
single shooter theory.
Now admittedly the magic bullet is a bit
strange,
but I don't think it was after the
rounds of possibilities a
do because of the fact the metal
particles.
There's more bullet fragments in
Connolly's body.
Then we're missing from that almost
pristine bullet.
And even though the fact that it hit
connolly at the very end,
if it went through all that flesh and it
didn't hit any bone until it hit his
wrist,
then it would not have been compromised
very much ballistically.
It would still be going incredibly fast.
It still would have smashed into that
bone.
It did enough to break his wrist and it
would have distorted the bullet.
That's just what happens with bullets.
See,
unfortunately,
I didn't really follow JFK conspiracy
very much.
And the reason I don't is that there are
already,
like I think literally over a thousand
[inaudible] I've read.
I've read a few,
um,
I got into case closed.
That was a Vincent Bugliosi book.
Is that who it was?
But I was like,
this guy's got an agenda.
It just didn't,
it.
There's,
there's many books that you could read
about the Kennedy assassination and some
of them favor the conspiracy and some of
them favor the assassination.
I think they have a lot of them have
merit on both sides.
One thing that drives me crazy when
people say that,
you could never make that shot,
that's fucking bullshit.
That's bullshit.
This is why I know it's bullshit because
it was only like a couple hundred yards,
like a couple hundred yards shooting it
something the size.
A person's head is easy.
What about Jesse Ventura trying to do
the a three,
three shots against shots.
Stuff.
He didn't know what he's doing,
but I mean first of all,
you would if you were used to that rifle
and you practice that,
someone said,
oh,
the scope was off.
I think that's bullshit too.
The reason why I think that's bullshit
is because it's easy.
Naca scope off.
You have to have a direct chain of
evidence between the time Lee Harvey
Oswald had that scope shooting that
rifle.
The moment he shot that rifle and then
you have to hand it off to someone who
checks the scope.
Right?
Then because if you drop a rifle,
the scope goes off.
Just drop it.
I've done that before.
I dropped a rifle once when I was
hunting in Wisconsin and my scope was
off by six inches at 100 yards.
Just dropping it.
So the idea that he could have never
made that shot because the scope is off.
Scopes get adjusted.
That's what happens when you drop a
scope,
they move.
That's a whole thing about ballistics.
You have to check them.
You go to the range,
you set up a a lead sled,
you lay the other rifle down so it's
perfectly stable.
You squeeze off a shot,
you use the binoculars,
you find out where the the shot hit on
the target,
and then you adjust the scope.
They're adjustable.
So the idea that his scope was no good,
it's crazy.
The idea that that shot was too far to
make insane.
It was only,
I think it was less than a hundred yards
when they think he made the first shot,
which is a chip shot.
That's the shot that you would make
without even arrest.
Now he's making this shot resting on the
window,
so he's perfectly steady.
The idea that that was impossible as
crazy.
The idea that no one can do that in
three shots,
that's been disproven.
Someone can do it.
Someone who's really good at reloading
and loading can do it just because Jesse
Ventura couldn't do it,
but Jesse super conspiracy mind is like,
he goes all in with the conspiracy
theorist,
the motivated reasoning part of doing it
just for a show or because he really
believes it.
I worked with the same people that did
his show,
the same people that did his show.
The reason why I did Joe Rogan
questions,
everything is they wanted me to take
over Jesse show after it was done and I
was uninterested.
I was like,
I'm not going.
I'm not that guy.
I'm not like the.
I believe every conspiracy guy.
I go,
I think there's people.
I think people have a real weird vested
interest in proving that things are
conspiracy.
I'm interested in finding out what
things really are like legitimately what
they really are.
Yeah,
and even if I'm wrong,
like I'm.
I have.
I'm not interested in reinforcing
things.
I've already said if I find out that
what I said was wrong,
I'm interested in repeating that I was
wrong as many times as they can to get
it out to as many people as I can.
Yeah,
I'm with you because I think it's
important.
So this,
this JFK thing,
there's bullshit on both sides of it,
but the idea that this guy who went over
to Russia,
married a Russian citizen,
came back here,
was it mean he was absolutely involved
in some shady,
weird shit with Cuba.
He's a fucking weird guy.
Harvey Oswald was a weird guy.
The idea that he was completely
innocent.
I'm not buying that either.
I don't know.
By the idea that it's proven that he
acted entirely alone.
It's entirely possible that the other
people who were helping him or
motivating him or giving him an
instructions even.
Yeah.
The thing I don't think has really
proven is the additional shooter theory.
It's not proven and there have been
people that said they heard things from
behind them.
The problem with that is chaos.
When you have gun shots,
first of all,
gunshots in an area where dealey plaza,
the echos,
echos,
ring out and people claim to see things
and hear things they even believed
themselves.
Have you tell someone that you heard
something in the bushes and then you run
away.
That person will say,
I heard something in the bushes and then
other people were repeated.
It becomes the narrative and it just
gets real hard.
Create memories for you can you can.
You're going to point to somebody and
say,
there is somebody there and they'll
think that was somebody that I liked it
because they.
Yeah,
the brain is so chaotically working form
was memories in a very weird.
Especially when it comes to something
that's so significant like the president
getting shot or any sort of violent
thing of this is something that gets
repeated ad nauseum about nine slash 11.
It's something that people point to
where they think that when the planes
hit those buildings that there was
detonations that caused tower one tower
two to fall.
There's no way they would've fallen like
that.
Like when people say no,
they heard things in the buildings,
they heard explosions.
People always say shit like that.
And on top of that,
if you're dealing with a building
collapsing like that,
you're gonna hear a lot of crazy shit.
Yeah,
yeah.
You gotta that all going to be
explosions,
things,
things are falling.
You know,
there were people falling off the
buildings which goes to to
tower seven.
That's another one that keeps coming up
the see if you can find the video.
Jamie,
there's a video that shows what really
happened in tower seven.
There's a guy who was a conspiracy guy.
He was really deep into conspiracies and
then the more he started looking into
tower seven,
the more he realized that everyone is
just showing the very final video where
tower seven collapses,
like a controlled demolition and it
looks exactly like a controlled
demolition.
However,
if you find the full video,
you see that the interior had collapsed
moments before,
like quite a bit before Edward Current.
I think the video,
that's exactly who it is.
See if you can find that gentleman's
video,
but he shows how the top of it,
you could see the of tower seven given
which is consistent with this idea that
the diesel fuel that they had in the
basement had created,
wasn't a diesel tank.
Yeah,
that was an early theory at the diesel
fuel,
uh,
that,
that was actually fueling the fire.
But they never found any evidence that
actually the diesel fuel contribution to
the fires,
it was just a regular office buyers,
which is what everybody finds those
associates.
Diesel never caught fire.
They might've been after the collapse.
Uh,
I think they're recovered one of the
tanks with some days I'll still in it.
So,
um,
series of diesel likely fed by a series
of diesel generators located in the
lower floors,
which is where most of the fires were
concentrated.
So at least one of the diesel tower,
a diesel tanks didn't light up.
Is that what you're saying?
The,
the theory,
this theory is that the diesel had
nothing to do with it.
Okay.
So nist,
which,
uh,
if you are a conspiracy theory person,
they get really angry when you bring up.
Is that the government,
the government man?
Um,
so I think this is an older video.
Yeah.
This isn't the video,
Jim.
There's one by Edwidge current.
Yeah.
And what it does is it shows the top of
the building cave in first quite a bit
before the rest of the building.
So this idea that it all cave in like a
controlled demolition because they
detonated all those things.
So Do,
do,
do.
Is that Edward Current?
I've got to find a good spot of the
video to show it.
So.
Okay.
Yeah.
So what happened,
what they think was that the fire,
this is shitty design of a building and
the fire caused internal damage to all
of the floors.
Well,
you see that,
uh,
the World Trade Center fell basically
against the side of a,
of seven.
Yeah.
It was back of the building was all kind
of like all the windows were broken on
the backside.
There was one column in the middle of
the back that was missing in a big chunk
of the,
uh,
lower west side was going to gouge it
out.
Right.
So this idea that it was just a fire.
Yeah.
It wasn't justified.
The fire is what triggered the collapse
eventually.
But the fact that all the windows were
missing from the south side contributed
a lot to that because you've got a lot
of wind flow through.
See if he's got the.
I Dunno mate,
maybe this is a bad thing to do while
you're actually doing the show.
So this is what the idea is,
the Nis computer models that all these
floors had collapsed inside.
Outside collapsed too.
Yeah.
But what this guy,
Edward current had showed in his video,
I think it was him,
was he showed that the top part that
past.
Yeah,
the top penthouse had collapsed first.
There it is.
CVC,
the pen house collapsing.
See is sinking it up.
But with the two,
the two videos,
the simulation.
So it's sitting up there and then boom,
you see it collapsed and so the windows
breaking down.
Exactly.
And that's that.
No one ever shows
and then it gives in,
right,
so this is not a quick thing like a
controlled demolition.
All those windows giving in is
indicative of all those floors
collapsing probably more than it is the
idea of the,
you know,
the people that want to see conspiracy,
think that those bombs were going off
there and that as those definitions or
explosions were going off that that's
what caused all those floors to collapse
on top of each other.
And I think that's what's talking about
what the core beliefs of the conspiracy
theories with nine slash 11.
This,
this back,
that world trade center seven looks like
a controlled demolition is core belief,
but when you actually get into something
and describe what's actually happening,
you have to go through a much more
complicated conspiracy theory at a much
more complicated way of looking at what
actually happened and now they're trying
to do a complicated study of World Trade
Center seven at the University of
Alaska.
This is something paid for by architects
and engineers when nine slash 11 truth
that trying to actually figure out how
they can reconcile controlled demolition
with the fact that it collapsed the way
it did,
so they're trying to actually explain
something which doesn't really need to
explain to him because the explanation
has been done by nist already.
So what they're trying to do is find
something that reinforces their initial
idea instead of it just look at the
facts itself saying,
Oh,
you look at the top of the penthouse
collapsing.
That's not indicative of a controlled
demolition.
That's indicative of the model that Nis
described,
which is a slow burn inside.
Extremely hot deterioration of all the
internal structure.
Everything starts to collapse inside.
And then the outside Clabsi to.
Well,
some of them will say that that is
actually how controlled demolitions are
done.
You blow up the interior of the building
first and then you blow the exterior of
the building.
Uh,
but the problem is that none of the
exterior columns were cut.
There was no explosion scene on the
exterior columns.
If you look at the World Trade Center,
one or two coming down,
yeah,
you can kind of imagine their explosions
going all the way down because of those
things that looked like explosions from
the folding floors,
but in seven you just see the building
kind of just going to crumble down.
So they have to kind of explain that.
So they come up with this study that
they funded.
It's custom,
nearly $400,000,
uh,
and they're trying to come up with an
explanation that doesn't involve fire a,
so that saying like if,
if it was controlled demolition than the
way they would have done it is blowing
up these interior columns a and it would
have pulled in the exterior and
collapsed the way we see in the video.
And I think that the,
some of them say that the penthouse
thing was a separate thing because they
wanted to have a neat demolition.
So they first of all blew up a few
floors just underneath the penthouse.
So neagley collapsed inside the building
and then they blew up some floors at the
bottom.
So he's all fell in itself without
damaging the surrounding buildings.
So they've got this complex theory and
it's based on confirmation bias.
It's based on confirming this idea that
this is a controlled demolition,
not on examining the whole thing as it
and going,
okay,
is it possible that the model is correct
and that these.
Look,
the thing that I bring up to people all
the time when they want to talk about
conspiracies,
there is a real conspiracy nine slash 11
and that's the fact that it happened.
The fact that they did fly planes into
buildings,
that's a conspiracy and they pulled it
off.
That actually did happen.
People don't want that to be it.
They want it to be a much broader
conspiracy involving world governments
that are trying to close in on,
you know,
all our rights and this is the way to do
it.
And
Yeah,
his proportionality,
people want something to be in
proportion to the size of the event when
they think just like a bunch of Arabs
with knives isn't a big enough cause.
So they think that it has to be
something.
We have more significant end,
even like with the physics of it,
they think he have the plane flew into
the building and it didn't collapse.
So why would it,
why would it collapse?
Some of them,
some people don't think that,
uh,
the plane we even have in the hall,
they think it would have been bounced
off or who the fluxing said,
oh,
some of them think that the,
the tower would have knocked over.
Really?
Yeah.
But these are people who have really no
conception whatsoever,
a physics and there's a minority of
people,
but you'll find people who,
who don't understand how aluminum can
cut through steel,
you know,
the columns of the exterior of the World
Trade Center were made of steel,
very strong steel and planes are made of
mostly aluminum.
So they don't understand how a plane
made of aluminum,
which is soft,
can go through steel,
which is very hard and strong.
And the example I always give to them is
the ping pong ball going through a ping
pong paddle.
If you make it go fast enough.
This is something I think mythbusters do
and various other people have done.
Uh,
you,
you send a regular ping pong ball a 500
miles an hour into a ping pong paddle
and it just goes straight through.
It leaves a ping pong ball hole in the
middle of it and that's just what
happened on nine slash 11.
The planes were going 500 miles an hour.
So you could do that with a ping pong
ball.
You can.
Wow,
that makes sense.
It's just,
well,
for the planes to the,
the amount of mass you're dealing with
two in the speed from 500 miles an hour.
Yeah.
And then you don't need to be,
it doesn't even need to be relatively
that much mass.
A ping pong ball,
it weighs one gram and a paddle weighs
like 200 grams or something.
So.
And you wouldn't think you've seen it.
You've seen ping pong paddles that is
laminated wood and rubber and you've got
this flimsy little bowl is how on earth
is that going to go through?
That switch is unintuitive,
right?
So you can understand how people would
be confused about why the planes left
these little road runner
civic and find that you had the
mythbusters thing.
I want to see that.
I hear it is.
Wow.
That was a whole.
So they have some crazy air cannon.
Yup.
Blows off.
Okay.
Here's the problem with that though.
Here's the problem with that.
They're doing that right in front.
I
have that they have to do with the pink
phone bulk because it will slow down,
but I understand.
But you're also with the
actual air.
Yeah,
right.
It's the.
But it is the ping pong table.
We can see it in slow motion.
Yeah.
Because what I was going to bring up was
a guy killed himself once accidentally
on a movie set because he took an
unloaded gun and he shot it into his
temple and it blew his brains out.
Yeah.
It was blank,
but the fact that it was a blank didn't
stop that air from blowing through.
There is a thing that people do when
they hunt in Alaska and in an incredibly
moist climates and places where there's
a lot of dirt and debris,
they will put tape over the top of the
rifle over the end of the barrel where
the bullet comes over or they even use a
condom and it has no effect whatsoever
on the accuracy of the bullet because
the air coming out of the rifle barrel
from the explosion blows that tape out
before the bill.
It even gets to it.
Yeah.
But you know,
the only reason they have to have the
thing right at the end of the barrel,
uh,
is the painful bowl,
but slow down in the say satellites.
If you felt something a little bit
heavier but still pretty small,
it will go through it.
Yeah.
No,
that makes sense.
And you think you've got to scale it up
like,
you know,
imagine like a beer barrel,
uh,
made a steel or aluminum weighs like 100
pounds or whatever.
What is full?
And he imagined that slamming into
something.
If I have a ping pong ball can do
something at 500 miles an hour,
uh,
be a barrel at five miles an hour.
I couldn't do it.
An awful amount of damage,
probably go right through a building.
Yeah.
And then you scale up from like a beer
barrel to a 200 ton plane.
Yeah.
And 200 tons hitting something at 500
miles an hour.
It doesn't matter that it's,
you know,
it's made out of aluminum.
It's still 200 tons of something.
If it was just a big bag of water
hitting something at 500 miles an hour,
it would still make a hole in the side
of the building.
I think this is a problem with a lot of
these theories is that a lot of the
people that are involved in these
theories are either not educated in what
they're talking about because there are
some various nuances to things like this
ping pong ball trick or they don't.
They don't want to be like,
they don't want to look at anything that
takes away from this conspiracy.
They don't want to look at anything that
debunks or disproves.
They just want confirmation of their
initial idea that this is some big grand
conspiracy that someone is in on it and
it's happening right before our eyes.
Yeah.
It's quite hard to even get one point
past a lot of people.
If someone starts out with that,
that theory,
that aluminum cannot cut steel,
then that just becomes the gatekeeping
obstacle that you have to get past.
If you can't disprove that one thing,
it does.
Nothing else matters really for them
because the,
you know,
the plane couldn't have entered the
building.
Therefore everything is a conspiracy.
So you,
you,
you kind of have to address these.
Yeah,
you have to.
In some,
it's important for people before they
decide that this is,
you know,
that the government spray and things in
the sky or that the world is flat or
whatever,
whatever these things are.
It's important to look at all the
evidence.
These youtube videos,
one of the real problems with them is
that they get to play out without being
interrupted.
Much like a podcast on unfortunately,
but they get to have these grand
statements without anyone who's an
expert stepping in and stopping them and
saying,
well,
that's not true and here's why it's not
true and here's why.
He can prove that it's not true,
which would just derail most of these
conspiracy theories really quickly.
Yeah.
And that's kind of the brainwash aspects
of these videos.
People,
uh,
people watch these three hour videos.
Kind of surprised me a first and I was
surprised that people would listen to a
three hour podcast,
but,
you know,
once you get going in something,
the first time I was on your podcast,
eight at the time went by light line,
nothing.
And if you're into something and you get
sucked into it and you,
you've got this really interesting
theory and it's like all these
revelations like,
oh my God,
I'm getting the,
the real skinny on the world.
Uh,
yeah,
you,
you just,
you just get sucked in.
And then when it's finished,
you on kind of a dopamine high and you
want to do more and you also feel like
you're in on something that people don't
know and you want to tell them about it.
Oh yeah.
And I've been there.
I've been there.
I've always tell people the dumbest one
ever believed in was a stupid tubes that
fly through the air.
Rogers or.
Yeah,
I was hook,
line and sinker.
I would go outside and I would try to
find those things streaking across the
sky.
Um,
what it was was that there was a video
that was made called Roswell rods and it
was trying to say that there was these
bugs,
like things that look like jellyfish,
that we're flying through the air so
fast.
The naked eye couldn't see them,
but they were catching on video cameras.
And then finally someone figured it out
that what it really was was you could
have an hd camera right next to a
standard definition camera and the
standard see those things flying across
the sky.
It's just a video artifact.
When the camera cannot pick up those,
those bugs,
it elongates them.
And streaks them across the camera.
Motion Blur,
motion blur.
And this guy,
this guy came to one of my,
uh,
UFC q and a's once and he waited in line
and he yelled out,
you're wrong about the rods.
The rods are real.
I can prove it.
Silly Fella.
But these,
that was a monster quest at proven that
on television they'd set up two cameras.
Yeah.
It's so hard when it's actually been
proven and you've got this conclusive
proof and yet there are still loads and
loads of people who believe in enrolled
doesn't look how it looks,
how he was describing that.
It looks like some kind of alien
jellyfish that's so fast.
It flies through the air faster.
You can see.
Yeah.
I mean the problem is these guys have
a vested interest in it.
Being real is motivated and not
necessarily by money.
They just motivated because once they
believe something,
they feel like that privy to this
special knowledge,
it's just going to be such a letdown if
they're wrong.
I think it's that end money man.
He sold.
He sold a bunch of videos.
I bought them.
I bought two of those bitches.
Oh,
I always try to start out with the
assumption that people are not,
you know,
they're basically good people.
They're not trying to make money.
Right.
Well,
I think they also get caught up in the
business of whatever it is.
If you're in the UFO business and then
someone comes along and shuts down your
business,
you're going to try to.
Well,
let me sort of.
They're not going to look at it
objectively.
They're gonna go,
I want to keep my business alive.
I want to protect my business.
Yes.
Yeah.
Almost like a architects and engineers
when nine slash 11 truth there,
they're like a half million dollar a
year business.
Uh,
they taking between 400 and $800,000
a year and the precedent of the,
the architects and engineers as he gets
paid a salary of $85,000
a year and he gets these expenses paid.
Now that doesn't mean that he doesn't
believe in what he's doing.
He,
I'm sure studied how it is like a
hardcore believer in nine slash 11
truth.
But over the last 10 years,
this has become his life and his
livelihood.
So even if he really believes it,
he still has this additional level of
motivation to not disprove things.
How many people are in architects and
engineers for nine slash 11?
Truth really depends how you count it.
Like they,
uh,
they say they have like thousands of
architects and engineers actually
signing the petition.
I think they have like a,
maybe a few hundred working structural
engineers.
Uh,
what do you think of their take on it?
That take is kind of like the standard
of a nine slash 11 truth.
They think that it's a controlled
demolition and I think they have all
this evidence.
We controlled demolition,
but it's not very good.
Evidence is,
uh,
one of the experts is a,
a high school physics teacher and you
know,
he's already fairly good at high school
physics,
but he just makes them very simple
mistakes about physics,
uh,
of the,
the folding towers.
And they repeat this on their website,
unquestioningly.
Uh,
there's another guy who's like the
expert on the Nano thermite residue that
was found,
you know,
they think that these reading grade
specs of what looks like a paint and
rust was actually a nano thermite,
uh,
since he's now like an expert on their
site,
he gets to say whatever he likes and
he's got this one theory about how the
bits of steel that flew out of the
building had these,
none of them like rockets attached to
them,
which is why they were leaving these
trails of smoke behind when they fell
down.
And these are things that are just
pretty ridiculous and you can kind of
debunk them with physics,
but they'll have none of it because
they've got the experts saying something
and you can't,
uh,
you can't deny the fact that you can't
deny that you can't to debunk their
experts because the experts,
you know,
where,
where would you knew more about a high
school physics teacher about physics?
Where would you know more about nano to
them?
Then this guy who was an expert in Nano
third,
right?
So that they've got all these supposed
expertise,
making these mistakes,
about nine slash 11,
like the,
the,
the president has this ridiculous
demonstration that he does where he
holds up to cardboard boxes and
underneath one of them is empty space
underneath the other one there's a,
there's a tower,
a drops them and the this one falls to
the ground and this one bounces off the
cardboard box and is basically saying
this is what should have happened.
This upper portion should have stopped
on the way down and it's using these
cardboard boxes and as a demonstration.
But the ridiculous oversimplifications
of what actually happened.
Yeah.
I don't know too much about the
engineer's take on things,
you know,
from architects and engineers.
I really didn't bother getting into it
too much,
but I just do know that it's several
hundred people if not over a thousand
and they're all over the world.
But how many people have studied it that
disagree with them?
Like how many and how good are the
artists that are in our.
I mean there's a lot of architects and a
lot of engineers
world.
Yeah.
That they recently tried to get a motion
passed at the American Institute of
Architects,
uh,
which was basically a reopen a world
trade center seven and they went to the
convention and they stood up and they
gave speeches and okay,
the,
all the evidence,
uh,
about why will the building seven
investigation to been reopened and they
took a vote and I think it was about
something like 97 to three present
against doing this.
So all of the architects who are
actually there,
these professional architects,
97 percent,
I can't remember the exact figures,
but it's around that voted against this.
So even though,
yeah,
even though there are thousands of
signatures to the,
a nine slash 11 petition who are
actually architects,
when you actually look at the actual
millions of architects that are out
there in the world is a very small
fraction of that.
Right?
But how many of those millions of
studied it.
I would like to see someone who's like a
real legitimate top of the food chain
architect from the deep debunking side
view it from someone who
is absolutely considered people.
Lots of people have done various studies
on nine slash 11,
the collapse of the building.
There was a book by a guy from London,
I think he's cool thing through a
Chinese guy from London who wrote a book
on a progressive collapses in large,
came out last year,
Twenty Sixteen,
and it discusses why buildings seven
collapsed,
why the World Trade Center towers
collapsed amongst a whole bunch of other
buildings.
Why we are the collapse,
so it didn't.
So there are lots of people who do
actually study it and within a nine
slash 11 architects and engineers when
nine slash 11,
they vast majority of them have not
studied it.
If you look at their position
statements,
if you look,
they asked everybody who joins it writes
a little statement which goes on the
website.
They'll say things like,
I watched loose change and that my eyes,
oh yeah.
It looked weird to me.
That's like the real common thing.
You know that when I saw the towers
fall,
I knew it wasn't.
Know the.
It wasn't very.
It wasn't a a regular collapsed.
It looked weird to me is my favorite
one.
It didn't.
But it did look weird.
It looks weird to me.
Says,
yeah.
Then an architect saying it looked weird
to them,
hey,
look what to everybody,
and no one has seen anything like that
before.
It was unprecedented.
You have the Saturn five rocket taking
off.
It looks weird because it hadn't
happened before.
Yeah.
There's a lot of things that look weird.
What other things do you think that you
and I disagree on A.
I think maybe the morgellons are more
jealous thing.
Oh,
you are more prone to think that is a
real thing because you went to the
morgellons conference.
Not that it's
thing that there's real fibers growing
out of people,
but that there's neurotoxic.
This is what I got from a doctor.
The doctor who had more Magellan's is at
the clinic who was a very reasonable
guy.
William Coffee I think is that his name
is.
He has lyme disease and he said the vast
majority of the people that have more
challenge also have lyme disease and he
believes that there is a neurotoxic
quality to lyme disease that affects the
way you see things and even causes
hallucinations.
And he witnessed it himself.
He said I had hallucinated and saw
something crawling across the surface of
my eyeballs in the mirror,
but it wasn't a real thing.
I couldn't see it after I looked at it
again,
it was gone.
But I did see it for a moment and he's
convinced that lyme disease,
when you catch lyme disease,
you're not necessarily catching.
It's not like you know you have tylenol,
you know something that's isolated.
It's very specific.
When you get tylenol,
you're getting tylenol.
He's like,
when you get bit by a tick that has lyme
disease,
you could get a host of pathogens and
there's what would test positive for
lyme disease.
It's very tricky to find someone to.
This doctor is when one guy,
William Lovey,
like he,
he's a guy who thinks he has more
morgellons or he thinks he has chronic
lyme,
but he definitely has chronic lyme and
he thinks that what morgellons is,
is a side effect of chronic lyme where
people start thinking there's fibers
growing their skin.
And so they think that fibers that come
from their clothes or carpets,
they get stuck to someplace they'd been
itching because they opened up a wound
and that they start
misinterpreting that as being something
that's grown out of their skin.
Yeah.
Well I would agree with that part of it.
But that's what he thinks.
So really,
he's not really a morgellons guy.
He's a chronic lyme guy.
Yes he is.
He's a more jealous guy in the fact that
he has seen the hallucinations,
but because of the fact that he's a
doctor and scientifically minded,
he believes that he's watching his own
mind play tricks on him and he thinks
there's neurotoxic qualities to whatever
the pathogens that are in lyme disease
are.
Yeah.
Well,
I guess I don't disagree with you too
much then I would disagree with you,
I think on chronic line,
but I think you probably know more about
it than I do from what I've seen.
Like most doctors don't think chronic
lyme is a real thing.
It depends on how long you have it for
before you get it treated.
That's the real issue is that there's
this lyme syndrome and chronic lyme,
which some people think there's a
chronic infection and other people think
that there's just chronic effects
leftover from having the lyme disease
for a long time.
I think there's a lot of variability.
I think one,
I mean I think we'd probably have to
really consult an actual lyme disease
doctor on this.
Not My area of expertise nor mine,
but I do have friends that have gotten
lyme disease and I know some people that
are suffering from it to this day that
have like real,
real terrible issues with it.
My friend Jim Miller,
who's a fighter in the UFC,
it's come and go with him and a terrible
way to affects,
greatly affects his joints and,
and you know,
he's had to take various medications,
try to get a handle on it.
It depends,
I think on the person.
There's a lot of,
a lot of variables.
It depends on the person,
depends on how quickly they detect the
lyme disease.
Um,
my friend brought his son to the doctor.
His son had lyme disease.
He brought us on to the doctor.
The doctor didn't believe he had lyme
disease because that,
you know,
the.
The Bullseye ring around the fight had
gone away,
which does sometimes happen.
They said,
Nah,
it's probably nothing,
and then the kid developed bell's Palsy.
Then they said,
okay,
this is serious,
and then they realized that he actually
does have lyme disease and he was pretty
pissed.
The doctor didn't take him seriously.
He had the lyme disease as well.
He had to go on some serious intravenous
antibiotics for months.
It was like really heavy stuff.
So we did actually have lyme disease.
He had lyme disease and it devastated
him for months.
For months.
He wasn't the same.
I think a problem with a lot of these
medical conditions is that the clinical
diagnoses,
which means that the diagnosed not with
tests,
that you can do a blood and things like
that,
but it's based on the symptoms.
Yes.
A lot of the times people,
they,
they like to attribute their problems to
something and gave it a name.
So we've got a lot of things now like
I'm a fibromyalgia a where we don't
have,
we can't do a blood test usually for
something like fibromyalgia.
He have elevated,
uh,
immune responses and things like that.
But you can't like Scifi show,
this is fibromyalgia.
It could be just a symptom of something
else.
But people like to put a name on things.
So if people have the getting aches and
pains
or wherever they say it's Fibromyalgia,
they convinced themselves as
fibromyalgia.
And with the self diagnosis,
with morgellons,
that happens a lot.
People,
people get old and your joints start to
ache.
Your hair starts to fall out in your
eyes,
start to,
you know,
you're losing your vision and your focus
and people think what's wrong with me?
And they don't realize they're just
getting old and they,
they look it up and they think they have
morgellons or they think they have
chronic lyme people just,
if they're getting ill for some reason,
they like to attribute the chronic
condition to something.
So they might tag on to a particular
thing like chronic lyme.
If something,
if they got bit by a tick,
uh,
like last summer and then this summer,
now they have all these problems.
They might self diagnosed as having
chronic lyme.
It is possible,
but you do realize that there's a
tremendous amount of lyme disease in the
northeast and lyme disease is very real
thing.
It's horrible,
horrible condition and the people that
do get it,
I mean they're pretty uniform and the
fact that it sucks,
it's a terrible and it's really scary
because it really didn't kind of exist
just a few hundred years ago.
I mean,
I don't know where it came from.
Yeah.
I just Kinda,
I don't know.
Or maybe they didn't know what it was.
People got it and no one had any idea
what it was.
Yeah.
It could be.
It was discovered that village lime,
which named after [inaudible] reminds me
of the Cuban embassy thing with a song.
Anyway,
what do you think about that thing?
I think
I don't think it's there is any signing
a weapon.
Why do you think that I.
because the,
it's the same type of thing.
People are reporting a bunch of
symptoms.
They haven't really done any direct
physical diagnosis of people.
People were getting ill,
people were reporting,
hearing noises,
uh,
but the noise is kind of sound like
cicadas.
Uh,
and so it could have been like one guy,
whites live in the middle of the night.
This is the gator in his room,
jumps out of bed,
scared.
He goes quiet.
And have you ever tried tracking as a
caterer in your yard?
And you get close to them and they go
quiet.
So you gotta start moving.
It gets back into bed,
skate assaults,
buzzing again.
So this time was the one guy say he
tells this story to someone or he gets a
little lighter,
some unrelated thing and other people
say like,
you know,
well,
I don't feel very well either.
And then,
uh,
at some point people sign up,
make a false connection and they start
thinking that something actually
happened.
And so they start asking people how you
feeling?
You feeling?
All right,
how's your hearing?
And people say,
well,
I'm here.
He's not as good as it used to be.
My eyesight's not as good as it used to
baby.
And having these balance problems,
but it's just people just having normal
normal life problems.
They're getting old or the near the
through sickness.
So they've moved,
moved away,
pull up,
pull up evidence of sonic weapon in
Cuba.
Because I don't,
I don't agree with you on this one.
The U s releases recordings of sonic
weapon attack used against diplomats in
Cuba.
Play this.
Sorry.
Bit like a skater to me.
Yes sir.
At least 22 people have been hurt by the
mysterious high pitch sound.
Have they have like 22 people are sick.
They're talk to their doctors and they
told them about the symptoms of people
with brain damage.
But it's a clinical diagnosis,
but you know that they have sonic
weapons,
right?
Yeah.
Have weapons or something that have been
researched and surreal in you don't
think it's entirely possible that this
is a sonic weapon.
I don't see any evidence.
There's,
have you looked into this a lot?
Yeah.
Um,
it seems to me that if they're
broadcasting it,
and this is something that the
government is talking about,
they're investigating and all these
different people are investigating it.
It seems like there's enough evidence
that are concerned if everyone's
reporting different things,
stressful conditions,
different weapon.
Second US deployments.
Cuba panel asserts Gabby can listen my
thing there,
right?
I Cuba like,
yeah,
they've got an interest in figuring it
out because they didn't want to get the
finger.
Yeah,
of course.
It's probably not Cuba doing it.
If it was somebody that will do this
after a nine month probe hampered by a
lack of success,
a lack of access to medical records.
A panel of Cuban scientists today
declared US diplomats here likely
suffered a collective psycho,
sympathetic psychogenic psychogenic
disorder.
Not Deliberate how fast.
Hysteria essentially.
So see if what evidence there is that is
pro this.
I typed in evidence and assist it.
This is what came up.
Yeah,
is the latest thing is.
But see if there's any other articles
contradict.
There is a later thing and then this
word has been.
They say the detective changes in the
white matter of the brain up some people
which is a bit vague and they did white
matter of the brain.
They using the Fmr.
What do they use them to find?
The.
I don't know how they did it,
but I can't even figure out cte and
players,
but who knows what caused this and how
many people actually habit and you know,
if one guy has changes in the white
matter of his brain,
who knows what that's actually due to
dot treating victims and the cat attack,
though I've found visible,
perceptible damage to the patients'
brains.
Marking the first solid evidence that's
sophisticated weapon described by
embassy staff is entirely real.
The associate Associated Press reports
says the Associated Press based on what?
Based on someone at the State Department
saying,
we're found,
uh,
some damage somewhere.
You know,
the State Department is covering their
ass.
The State Department expelled Cuban
diplomat because of this.
They did.
Meanwhile,
the Cuba.
That's our mine.
We did nothing.
Go back up there please,
because Rebecca at the top,
they took some Americans away from the
embassy because they were sick.
And so they said the Cubans didn't
protect the American as well.
He know.
So you're going to have to send six
people back as well.
See,
it says the State Department,
the FBI officials.
Uh Oh.
It's so unlike anything,
the State Department,
the FBI officials I've ever seen that
the Cuban government's claim,
the high pitched worrying sounds
reported by the US embassy staff are
just cicadas.
Seems almost plausible.
Click on that link that says they're
just cicadas up at the top.
That,
but the same one we just saw her,
I think.
Is that it?
Yeah.
Playing the noise.
Hm.
This is a similar attack happen to
somebody else in Uzbekistan.
Is that Bush?
Oh really?
Yeah.
Old School Bush.
Why they have a picture of is being
attacked by us again.
Okay.
Yeah,
I did it all.
I'm too weird sound for sure.
But I would think that um,
something that would be,
uh,
that you,
that could damage you would be a
frequency.
That would be audible.
Yeah.
Well some of them reported hearing
things,
but you know,
people,
some people didn't report hearing
things.
Some people had a high pitch whine that
disappeared.
Some people had a long lasting rumbling
noise.
Some people might not be.
Sonic vision changes all kinds of
different,
you know,
just your regular morgellons common
chronic fatigue.
Getting old type symptoms.
Hm.
So you think that someone started
talking about this being an issue,
that they're being attacked and
everybody started freaking out?
Yeah,
that's possible.
and I think probably something happened
like the esm guy heard something and
jumped out of bed and it stopped and
then got back into bed and it started
again and someone else had something
similar happened.
That's funny because if you were in Cuba
and they didn't want you there and you
heard weird noises like goddammit,
they're attacking me with a sound ray
and people are being.
People are being harassed in Cuba.
Like if you work at the American
embassy,
you get harassed.
New Sonic attack against American
diplomat suggest Russian involvement.
Palm Palm,
Palm.
The Russians did it through twitter
bots.
When you click on the twitter bots,
they send sound through your earbuds.
Yeah.
People are saying like,
you know,
linking the CICADAS,
causing the hearing loss.
But no one's actually saying the CICADAS
are causing people to lose their
hearing.
They just saying that,
you know,
people sometimes get reductions in their
hearing as they get older and maybe
they're noticing it because they're
focusing on it so much.
Right.
That's why those diseases,
people think I'm sick and then they
focus on something.
Like if you feel like you're itching a
bit and you think you've got some kind
of weird pathogen under your skin,
you just gonna itch more and more,
you're going to feel more and more
itching.
Right.
So if people weren't really paying
attention,
like I have like mild tinnitus,
ringing in the ears from video games or
something,
I dunno.
Headphones they said yeah,
it could be.
But you know,
people get tested,
get older for no reason.
Some people you're going to loud
concerts or whatever.
Most of the time I don't even think
about it in my.
I might have never even noticed it,
but if I stopped and listened to my,
you know,
what's going on in my ears,
I can hear this tonight is the noise in
my ear very,
very quietly.
So if someone said,
oh,
I think we're being bombarded by sonic
weapons like a.
can you hear any ringing in your ear or
anything like that?
And then you go quiet and you listen and
you start noticing these things.
Right.
That makes sense.
Do people are very susceptible,
you know,
psychosomatic illnesses,
they're absolutely very real.
And this,
there's a thing called sick,
sick building syndrome,
uh,
which is possibly a real thing and
possibly a psychogenic thing,
but a lot of people think that a sick
building syndrome,
a lot of the times when it happens,
it's like when you.
Lots of people working in the same place
get similar symptoms,
it's happening because of this mass
psychogenic illness.
One person says,
I feel sick and everyone kind of assumes
it's something in the environment around
them that's causing that.
And so they kind of feel sick as well.
This a disease.
And I had heard of someone's talking
about this one's called Allah phrenia I
believe,
and that it's when people go to visit
people who have schizophrenia,
when they,
if they hang out with those people,
they start developing very bizarre
behavior of their own.
And sometimes they have to be monitored.
And that's kind of weird.
Yeah,
that sounds well.
We all know that some people are way
more susceptible to suggestion way more
susceptible to him.
Have you ever been hypnotized?
Now?
I haven't.
I have.
It's fascinating.
Yeah,
I,
I feel like I wouldn't be hypnotizable
saying that everybody thinks that I
thought that too,
but I did it with a friend.
My friend Vinny shoreman did it to me,
so I trusted him and I just let it and
he's a registered licensed hypnotist and
he works with a lot of athletes,
a lot of fighters in particular and
basically just puts you in a very
bizarre state of mind,
but you're aware of it the whole time.
It's not like some mentoring candidate
thing where they're going to wake up mic
now you're an assassin for the
government and you'll run out the door
and your underwear like captain
underpants.
Do you know captain underpants says,
do you have kids?
No,
but I do know her.
Yeah.
My kids love captain underpants.
Friend of mine told me I should try
hypnotizing my wife.
He didn't specify exactly the way he,
uh,
he keeps his relationship going is by
hypnotizes them every couple of nights.
He hypnotizes his wife and just,
uh,
I don't know.
I didn't know exactly what happens.
He's actually,
he didn't really specify,
but he,
he highly recommended humanizing my
wife.
Wow.
That guy sounds like a creep.
He's doing some weird shit to his wife
who's a nice guy,
but maybe not when he's got that,
that stopwatch hanging on a string.
Why was,
it was always a watch.
Right?
Follow the watch.
Very.
You're kidding.
TRIPI.
Yeah.
Um,
that's real hypnosis.
Israel.
I was wondering,
I was like,
oh.
what is this like?
Is it the bullshit?
But they,
it really does put you in a very unusual
state and when you get out of it there,
you know,
you can go through a lot of stuff that
you have like maybe cluttering around
inside your mind and reorganize after a
hypnotic session.
It's pretty interesting.
It's a reason why people use it for
like,
you know,
quitting smoking and things on those
lines.
Yeah.
Well,
this just shows how malleable the human
brain is.
Yeah.
Uh,
and you know,
it goes back to that whole thing with
being brainwashed by youtube,
you know,
people make documentaries,
uh,
in a way to hypnotize people.
They,
they,
they structure it in a way that you get
these images coming at you and these
ideas and they slaves reinforcement of
things in a way that will actually just
kind of embed this idea in your brain
without you even really realizing it.
Yeah.
They'll say things like you are being
lied to.
And with the,
the thing that kills me too is that they
use oftentimes a hypnotic voice like
that.
Eric Do,
big Iowa does those flat earth videos.
He talks in a very hypnotic manner.
It's like very calm and yeah,
I think so.
The nine slash 11 videos as well.
This nice woman dictating it behind the
buildings could not possibly a fall in
the way they did.
Physics proves it.
Uh,
it looks like we're going to have eric
do bay.
He said he's agreed to do it.
Talk with Neil degrasse Tyson.
We're going to,
he's going to skype in from Thailand or
wherever the fuck he is.
Yeah,
I think it's in Thailand.
I don't know how he gets there with flat
earth.
How'd you get here?
That's still in the northern hemisphere.
I think Thailand scoop over there.
Shoot over there and avoid the ice wall.
But he doesn't believe in dinosaurs
either.
It's kind of a crazy guy.
No Way.
You think he doesn't believe in say,
I don't know if he believes in
satellites,
but I don't think he believes in nuclear
bombs.
Antisemites as well.
I think it was him.
Yeah.
That's unfortunate.
Subculture in the movement of A.
Yeah.
Nazis type people.
Well,
because of the conspiracy theory goes
back to,
you know,
the rothschilds running the world.
And so they think is these,
uh,
you know,
this certain sector of the Jewish race
who weren't actually in control of
everything.
And these are the people who were
stopping you from the debate is not me
saying this.
I have no knowledge whether or not
you're anti-semite don't chicken out.
It's pretty easy to verify a bunch of
videos explaining his position on it.
My favorite thing is that he's my friend
Eddie Bravo is kind of buying into some
of his shit.
Witch tortures me to no end,
but Eddie is one of the greatest Jujitsu
coaches on planet earth.
He's an amazing Jujitsu coach in Jujitsu
competitor and one of Eric [inaudible]
biggest videos is about how Jujitsu is
bullshit.
It just shows you.
It does,
isn't it?
About that.
It's about wing Chung Kung Fu defeats
Jujitsu,
which is by the way,
not true.
Don't try it unless you're like way
bigger and the guy sucks that Hugh
Jitsu.
She those guys in a room together and
they can just fight it out.
I don't think so.
They would just talk about conspiracies
to the end of time.
Eddie loves conspiracies.
I would like to talk to Eddie.
We can do that.
He's screaming,
screaming.
Might have to get you some earplugs here
tonight.
I said kick him.
He's interesting because he knows so
much about them all.
Oh man,
that's really interesting.
Confuses me.
I'm like,
how much time do you have?
Where do you have the time for this?
Yeah.
He's spouting off this advanced physics
references like Mickelson areas,
failure and things like that.
Those are the flat earth science
experiments that supposedly proved the
wasn't moving.
That one's hilarious to me because when
I first brought it up to Eddie,
Jamie pulled this up and send it to me
the other day that I first brought it up
to Eddie from like eight years ago on
the podcast,
one of the really early podcast when we
still did it in my house on a couch and
he's like,
what's the most ridiculous conspiracy
theory?
You're hurt?
And I said flat earth,
and he's like,
no,
people don't believe the earth is flat.
So he went from that to.
I don't think he's at 100 percent
convinced that it's flat,
but he's definitely willing to listen.
He's down the rabbit hole.
He got sacked and he loves it and it's
probably like a lot of it is just from
him watching endless youtube.
It's 100 percent what it is.
Here it is right here.
The worst conspiracy to like the worst
one,
flat earth.
There's people that are flat to the
young earth.
That's another bad one.
No,
no,
no.
Like today,
people don't believe that that's a big
percentage of the Christian population
dying.
I went with young earth there for some
fucking stranger.
We were all baked.
Oh,
probably unfortunately.
But that was,
that was when he found out about flatter
for me.
And that was,
you started him down the rabbit thousand
episodes ago.
What episode was that?
Fifty four.
So that was probably 2010.
First year.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it doesn't.
That was even big on the Internet by the
head of the curve.
Maybe responsible for this whole thing.
Well,
he and I used to watch ufo things
forever,
but he got off a Ufo.
See,
he goes in waves,
right?
Eddie goes in waves.
We were both like really into Ufos.
And in particular Zechariah situation,
that was the big one.
You know,
Zechariah stitching is,
I think you've talked about it,
unless the Sumerian text guy,
he wrote a the reason why a 10th planet
Jiu Jitsu is June 10th planet Jiu Jitsu.
Um,
I actually came up with the name and one
of the reasons why I came up with the
names because we were talking about
Zechariah stitching and the idea is
that,
um,
this,
this came from another planet.
We actually came up with the name before
Pluto had been changed from a,
you know,
they decided as a downgraded it.
So we decided that this Jujitsu was
coming from another planet like out
there where the Annunaki live,
but it was based on Zechariah Hitchen's
book,
the Twelfth Planet.
And his book was all about Planet Nibiru
and that the Sumerian texts were when
you,
when you decide for them correctly,
they all described this ancient race
that came from this other planet that
has this elliptical orbit that comes in
between Earth and Mars and Jupiter
somewhere somewhere.
It comes near Earth every 3000,
600 years and that there's a group of
beings called the Annunaki created human
beings by coming down here and taking
them and taking lower primates and
injecting their dna into them and blah,
blah,
blah.
We were,
we were balls deep into that.
That was a big one.
Yeah,
type thing like the ancient aliens,
there's something that's really at the
far end of the conspiracy spectrum,
but you still get people who like,
you know,
chem trail,
believers who believe it.
One of the guys you interviewed a Scott
Stevens.
There's a meteorologist.
Yes.
Yeah.
He was into like,
he believed chem trails 100 percent.
Yeah.
He also believes in aliens and they did
it that type of hockey,
like white holes and things disbelieve
in aliens.
What I disbelieve is people that are in
contact with them,
right?
Yeah.
I think the idea of,
you know,
the Fermi Paradox,
right?
The idea that there's so many planets,
so many galaxies and so many solar
systems that the odds of life being out
there so high.
Why,
why have we not been contacted?
That's interesting to me.
Um,
it is entirely possible in my
estimation,
as a moron,
that we are the most advanced life form
in the universe.
It's entirely possible because we exist
because we are the most advanced life
form on earth.
We know that,
right?
As far as we know,
as far as like communicating things that
we've discovered in 2017,
we are the most advanced.
It's entirely possible that were the
most advanced everywhere.
So I want.
It has to be right.
It could be us,
me,
yeah.
People say like,
you know what are the odds,
but you know,
what are the odds of us?
The first person,
you know,
whoever wins the lottery because by the
Alex,
but he happened to that person.
It doesn't mean that it's very unlikely.
It's not like we're running lots of
universities and see what happens was
also there's a direct one progression
that you could follow.
Like what are the odds of someone
inventing the iphone 10 and 2017.
Well,
I don't know what that's how long it
took.
That's what happened.
That is exactly what happened.
This is what we track it.
We can go back to the iphone 1:10
years ago.
It's real simple.
People.
People use the argument.
It's like what is the probability,
right?
In weird ways.
Like people say,
what is the profitability of three
planes falling from two free free
buildings falling two planes hitting
them,
because if that argument actually makes
any sense.
Shitty argument.
Yeah.
They bring it up all the time.
It's like,
what are the odds you who get so lucky
that you would have three planes pre
buildings on the same day.
This doesn't make any sense.
No,
it doesn't,
but people
don't say things like the end,
but again,
again,
it's to support confirmation bias,
so I think that it's entirely possible
that we the only advanced life form in
the universe or it's entirely possible
that they are incredibly advanced
lifeforms that really aren't interested
in us and quarantined.
Yeah.
That's possible to look at our fucking
president and we have a wacky president
that's just lies all the time.
I mean fucking mind.
I think the purpose was studied
crunching as a bit a bit earlier,
but what would you see?
What you would go.
These people don't know what the fuck
they're doing.
We need to figure out if they're going
to blow each other up and pay close
attention to them.
See if they don't poison their water,
like figure out what they're going to do
first before we give them new technology
or anything.
You okay with people?
If this thing's out there?
It's probably machines.
Well,
I think it's.
You look at the advances in ai and stuff
that's going on now.
I don't think there's many civilizations
can really survive sync.
Biological life has its time.
Yeah,
because you know,
people talk about lighting a terminator
and skynet and things like that and the
robots taking over and I think that's
actually a real problem.
I think we.
You seem like these robots.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
They're pretty crappy now,
but yet got to the stage where they can
do back flips and things and it's not
too much further along the line like a
hundred years from now.
It's like a blink at the universities.
I will have robots that can do
everything that humans can do and more
absolutely indistinguishable to from
from people and how you choose to be and
but not just any distinguishable.
They will be humans.
Plus they'll be like gods.
Yeah,
they will.
We do hundreds,
thousands or millions of times more
powerful than humans in terms of the
processing power and news,
hundreds of times more powerful in terms
of their strength and that's 100 years
from now.
Yeah.
We're really close to that.
Yeah,
because it's going to be an explosive
thing.
This,
this thing in ai now cold.
Um,
uh.
Oh.
Alrighty Dan,
because I forgot.
It was a generative adaptive networks
which has this way of doing ai where the
robots basically basically teach
themselves.
They have one robot who is judging
things and there's a robot that's
creating things and the robot that's
creating things teaches the robot that's
judging things,
how to judge and the robots,
the judging things,
teachers,
the creating robots how to create and
then they just go back and forth,
back and forth.
So the old way of doing ai was like you
would teach a robot to do things and you
correct it when it goes wrong and you
tweak the algorithm,
but now you've got these robots that are
learning things incredibly,
incredibly rapidly by teaching
themselves how to do things.
And the humans who are running these
robots don't actually understand how
this actually works.
You end up with this huge big matrix of
numbers which,
you know,
no one can actually decipher,
but the results come out of it that
they've got things like now where
you can,
uh,
you can take a scene in a video and you
can turn night into day or you can turn
a snow scene into a summer season
because they can,
you know,
the robots and the ai knows how to do
these things.
And this is just the tip of the iceberg.
There's so much more coming down the
line.
Yeah.
I,
I saw something that was incredibly
disturbing.
They said that when robots become
sentient,
like when they have the ability to make
up their own decisions and do things for
themselves and they first thing they're
going to do is improve upon their own
design.
Yeah.
And they'll,
they'll will be able to have 10,000
years of human propel.
Like if,
if humans were evolving technology,
a robot or a sentient ai could do 10,000
years worth of technological advancement
in two weeks.
Yeah.
And is that real?
Yeah,
because computers just run so much
faster.
Just think about that number two weeks.
So think about how long ago,
10,000
years ago was for civilization.
That is probably a little bit optimistic
in terms of like actual physical
development because they can't make
prototypes fast enough to try the out
with.
Again.
They don't sleep.
They will.
They'll have these little robots.
Then the enemy fuck robots can move so
much faster.
We do kill them.
Pioneer.
So scientists acts.
Some scientists are saying that we
should actually not.
We should put the brakes on this Ai.
A lot of them,
right?
Yeah.
But it's funny thing that seems like
we're moving towards the edge of the
cliff and everyone's going,
hey,
we should probably hit the brakes.
It's also such a lucrative thing for
people to do because if you get really
good ai you can.
You can sell it.
Yeah.
And the army is going to want robot
soldiers.
Yeah.
You've got these,
these,
these drones with guns mounted on them.
If you imagine you've got like you.
That scares the shit out man.
What are you showing me?
This I'm going to hit play.
It's really fast.
It's sorting a ripe ripe tomatoes really
quick.
It'll slow it down here in a second
fastest.
Whoa.
How can it see the.
Oh my God.
So it sees the green tomatoes and it
just knocks him out.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Because the computer is essentially
seeing what we're seeing now.
He's hitting them.
So.
Perfect.
That's insane.
So as they're coming down this ramp,
these computers are.
Oh my God.
That's in real time.
Yeah.
Holy Shit Dude.
So he's got this computer vision that's
processing it and because computers are
fast enough to do this now,
my God,
we're fucked.
It's just gonna get festival.
So fucked.
That scares the shit out of me more than
the backflipping robot.
Imagine that backflipping robot can move
really fast.
Yeah.
Well that's what Elon Musk said.
You won't be able to see him use.
Have a strobe light.
Yeah.
And you know they're going to be super
accurate shooting things and take your
eye out.
Yeah.
They're not gonna have any trigger
panic.
Just going to be able to just be like
robots.
God Damn it.
So that's,
that's a real,
that's a real to put down the chem
trails,
walk away from the flat earth and
understand that there's sentient robots.
What did you,
okay,
you,
you have a background in computers.
What did you,
what was your take on that whole thing?
When Google had to shut down these two
computers,
communicating with each other because
they started talking in a language that
they didn't understand the.
I mean,
that's what I was talking about that
with the generative adapted networks,
they uh,
they didn't have to shut them down,
but they did because they were a little
freaked out.
Oh,
they shut them down because they
couldn't do anything with them.
It was the two,
two computers talking to each other in
Gobbledygook.
Say if it was something interesting,
they would have kept them and studied
it.
The thing that they knew what the
computers are saying,
computers knew what they're saying to
each other.
No,
no.
It was just some kind of loop that they
got stuck in.
It probably wasn't particularly
intelligent or anything so much more
ominous to say that they have the
language they weren't like plotting to
take over the world.
How do you know it's because we aren't
there yet,
but they would've already done it.
The first things computers do sexually
harass each other.
They send Computer Dick Pics.
What would that even look like the other
day?
Like what's the AI gender going to be?
Has anyone decided or has it been talked
about?
Maybe that's what's going on with all
this crazy push to accept 78 different
gender pronouns and non binary people
and all this stuff that didn't exist in
the past.
Maybe were move.
Maybe there's like a natural inclination
in the human species to move towards a
genderless prototype of the future.
We,
we went into this in depth yesterday
under the influence,
obviously we did a podcast.
We were talking about like what an alien
is the archetype alien with the big head
in the very thin body and the mouth.
It's like barely visible that.
I think that this is probably what we
see ourselves becoming when we have some
sort of a symbiotic relationship with
technology.
When technology becomes a part of us,
when we have the ability to manipulate
genes,
which is absolutely coming,
and then we have this enormous head,
which I mean look at our heads,
right?
It's not very practical.
Enormous head.
Neil degrasse Tyson was talking about
this recently being all over the place.
They were talking.
He was talking to Ray Kurzweil in a
podcast.
I was listening to Ray Kurzweil,
the futurist,
and they were talking about the size of
a human head and that human head could
only get so big because of the mortality
issue with the mother,
like the mother could not give birth to
the head can only be so big and that
it's also one of the reasons why folding
over the skull in our heads are so big
that we have to be born like almost
helpless as opposed to like other
animals that are born.
They're pretty pretty agile,
like right out of the box,
like a deer or a horse or something like
that.
Or even primates.
Primates have very little body fat on
them and they're.
They're much stronger than a young human
baby and that the design of the vagina
in the head like leaves,
little room for advancement in the state
that we're going as far as it can go,
but if we move away,
I was thinking from China,
from Vagina's not,
not,
not genres,
ladies.
That's not what I'm saying,
but what I'm saying is move towards some
sort of a.
A Vat.
Yeah.
Something there can put together in some
sort of a new concoction,
some sort of a new artificial womb that
doesn't have any size constraints.
Why don't you want a big hat?
Well,
if you don't give a fuck about what you
look like,
the big head would allow you to see the
future that you could have massive cut
like that.
That would.
That's a freaky one.
That's not ready yet because it is a big
head.
Well,
there's that version of the alien or
there's the bodybuilder alien from
fetus,
which seems less likely.
It's just a grunt.
I think just the missing link.
So now.
But I think like with the big head
thing,
like I don't think you need to grow
bigger brains behave and you could
probably do a lot better by having some
kind of implant silicon type thing and
that little computer running in your
brain.
But what if you had a huge computer,
like 100 iphones,
dom,
he covered a bigger brains as well
because there's a limit to that.
Let's apply like your brain is already
using if you're using so you can have to
have oxygen tanks so strapped to your
back to what if we go away from all that
stuff?
What have they figured out?
Some sort of a vision way.
Just have like a,
Whoa,
what is this?
Before there's a.
They put a lamb out and had it in an
artificial womb and it survived for a
few weeks at least when I was growing up
or we were like a few weeks.
I worked a little sort of science
fiction.
Now what will.
But I think that's entirely possible for
the future.
And then the idea of human beings moving
away from biological bodies and if they
figured out a way to download
consciousness,
which is one a Kurzweil's things,
right?
To figure out a way to get to a point
where consciousness is something that
can be transferred as a freaky idea that
freaky to me because as someone like Kim
Jong,
Uhm,
we makes a thousand of himself and
fucking put them all over the world.
What if consciousness gets taken over,
but it's,
you actually die and you just.
This robot facsimile of you is what
continues.
What if you make two copies of yourself?
Yeah.
Do you want them as a sky diver?
The trial bull riding?
Because if you can hit a button,
download someone's consciousness.
You can you imagine if that's what you
decided to do.
You just do all reckless shit with one
of your body and you start mma fighting.
And then would you like download that
experience back into your other buddy?
Yeah,
I'll just die.
No,
you would download it.
You'd have the other body on steroids
and you have the other body like working
out at the Olympic training center.
And turn the other body until like a
super athlete and then the one that you
sky dive in and doing backflips with the
augmented brains,
they're going to come along before
things like that.
I think you're,
I think it's something
that with ai is coming along is like a
bots chat bots on the Internet actually
creating content.
Yes.
Not just like creating,
like talking things like posts on
Youtube.
They can create pictures like these,
you know,
these networks I was talking about can
actually create videos that looked like
real videos.
So I think you're going to get actual
content creators which are artificial
intelligence,
like youtube personalities that are
actually artificial intelligence.
But some of them will be overt like,
you know,
the is Google's new bots,
posting on the Internet going,
hey everybody,
I Google,
uh,
and then you'll get people,
you'll get ais pretending to be real
people and then you get these ais
pretending to be real people in
thousands if not millions of social
media accounts trying to influence
people.
Wow.
Then you talk about like Bot nets and
things,
but that just like people just posting
shit like reposting memes and things,
what if you actually get an artificial
intelligence that can actually hold a
conversation with someone at an
artificial intelligence that's actually
more intelligent than the person that
you're holding is holding the
conversation with it.
We'll be able to manipulate that person
and control them and since it's a
computer doing it,
you could have thousands or millions of
them and you could do all kinds of
targeted like social media campaigns
going on right now.
Yeah,
but they're not.
They're not actually like a habit.
It's not an artificial intelligence
having a real conversation with people.
We're on the verge of that,
but they do have artificial bots that
will go out and attack.
People do have things on those.
The simplistic things.
They're spamming things.
You can tell there are bought fairly
easily for now.
Yeah.
We're getting to the stage where you
won't be able to tell that it's the
ball.
They'll be someone who would be in in a
few decades.
There'll be people,
there'll be artificial intelligence is
that will be just as intelligent as you
or me and we'll be able to have the same
conversations on social media that you
and I can have on social media right now
and people wouldn't be able to tell.
The difference is this big famous test
in ai,
which is the cheering test where the
test is.
Someone sits in a room with a typewriter
and they talked to the computer in the
other room when,
if you can tell it's a computer,
uh,
then it passes the turing test and it's
meant to be intelligent and they can't
tell that it's a computer.
Yeah.
If as a computer.
So there's been very limited successes
with that if you like,
restricts the topics to just baseball or
Britney spears or something like that.
They had these very limited domains that
they can talk about that if you get a
general purpose ai that is actually
intelligent and can and has goals to
change someone's mind about something
like politics,
you could have a real problem.
Well,
we were talking about Duncan and I
yesterday were saying think about
someone creating an artificial version
of him based on the hundreds of hours of
his audio recordings because he has so
many podcasts as do I know if somebody
wanted to take a
like mine where there's a thousand
episodes and take those thousand plus
episodes and take my opinions and the
way I describe things,
the way I talk.
I mean like if you're talking to me in a
podcast like this,
you're just talking to me.
This is what I talk like,
so.
And you'd get a bunch of variables,
right?
You get me excited,
me depressed me,
shocked me,
sad me.
Happy.
You would have so much to choose from.
Yeah.
You could look kind of material.
You could kind of like fill in the
blanks and guests pretty accurately.
How I would react or respond to certain.
One of the episodes of Black Mirror,
British TV show,
great show.
Yeah.
It was about some woman whose husband
had died,
but he had all this video of him.
There was a service that set up an ai
version offerman and it starts out
small,
like someone who would post on social
media as him and eventually it grew to
be this don't spoil alert me.
Right.
I just watched an episode of the.
The other day is a good.
That one.
Thank you.
It's a good episode.
Oh,
so good.
I watched one the other day about the
video games that they put that thing in
the back of your head.
Did you see that one?
It's in the new season.
This also too.
God Damn.
It's good.
That's a great show and it's come out a
couple of weeks.
Three weeks,
man.
Joe Rogan does not like it though.
Freaked out.
It is a bit creepy.
I think she hears too much of that shit
from me to,
you know,
she just gets freaked out on technology
in the future.
The possibilities.
But yeah,
like making a fake.
Jurgen is something that is possible to
easy.
You can probably do something if they
put enough resources in just.
Yeah,
just Joe Rogan.
Yeah.
They could have something because this
type of,
you know,
the,
the genitive adaptive generative
generative adversarial networks,
this thing where they got one judge in
one generator,
they'll have one ai that just tries to
make Joe Rogan's and then they'll have
another ai that,
an expert at detecting the real Joe
Rogan and it'll have all this real
material to go by and then this will
keep feeding things at this and say,
well,
that's not quite right.
He doesn't say like that.
He narrows his eyes when he's confused
and wow.
And eventually it will
come up with something that resembles
you will.
Then it becomes a thing of like,
how do you know you're you and how do
you know you're talking to someone else.
That's them.
Like,
here's the thing.
Let's just say,
why'd you leave this rubber Dick to
sitting right here?
Rude.
Chris Ryan gave me a rubber Dick.
Sorry,
I just noticed it.
I looked over,
had a comment.
Say,
let's say if,
uh,
say your father died,
which is one of Ray Kurzweil's big
things.
His,
one of his primary motivations is to
recreate his father.
He lost his father when he was young and
he believes that through the advent of
artificial intelligence and through the
data that is collected
to recordings of his father and the
images that one day he will literally be
able to communicate with his father.
Again,
I don't know if that's real,
but I do know that someone like Dunkin
save my friend Duncan died.
It's entirely possible that within the
next 50 years they're going to be able
to create a version of Duncan and Duncan
can come over and say,
hi,
I'm back.
Hey,
crazy.
I was dead and I won't even know.
I won't know if it's really Duncan.
You've gotta watch this episode of Black
Mirror that okay,
don't tell me.
Don't tell me,
but is it for to remember where I found
us,
I think it was an NPR episode of
might've been on radio lab thing called
dad bought.
This guy made literally a text.
He used all of his dad's past text
messages between himself and him and
then made a Ai Bot he could chat with.
I think his brother can use it to.
They can just send generic messages
like,
Hey,
how you doing?
And He sends something that he would
accept
back.
Meanwhile,
your dad's like,
shut up,
faggot.
He Dad just says shit to you.
A little pussy.
You're never gonna amount to nothing.
Oh,
dad bod.
That's what your dad was like.
They wouldn't do that.
Yeah,
you can probably tweak it a bit though.
Just asking to dilate down type of thing
is coming.
They're like text now and it's not,
it's not like very good.
You'd be able to tell.
It's not a real person.
Did you like x Mokena?
Uh,
what was that the movie?
You never saw it?
Oh yeah,
I did see it,
but I've,
I forget.
I forget very,
very quickly.
That's amazing.
Was it was a plot real quick.
The plot was,
there was like some,
some wishes in a house,
super scientists who lived in the middle
of nowhere and they'd be flown into him
and he had created that guy right there
creating artificial intelligence and
then went over the turing test and
everything in that too.
It's my,
one of my favorite movies.
That's my top 10 favorite movies of all
time.
It hits so close to home and they were
so little cut the shit in that movie.
You know,
I described movies based on the cut the
shit scenes,
like someone who was like,
what?
Oh fuck is she cut the shit.
How the hell did that happen?
There was none of that in that movie to
me.
That in that movie to me was like,
wow,
like this,
uh,
this all could take place.
It's paid there with these future robot
things.
So much of it is just trying to make a
robot that just like a human.
When the robots are not going to be like
humans,
they're going to be like,
silence is going to be,
you know,
more than humans at your command rooms
doing work that I'm going to look like
humans because it's not very practical.
There will be robots that look exactly
like humans,
but that's just one aspect of it.
There's going to be all kinds of much
more impressive robots I think of that
tomato robot.
Yeah.
It's knocking.
It didn't have to look like a person
just has to be functioning the way it to
be.
For it to be functional.
It's not to look like a person.
Exactly.
It's to have these multiple fingers that
can knock away these green tomatoes.
So why?
Why,
why build something around the
limitations of the human body.
This is the same guy that isn't that
black mirror.
Episode two.
Oh,
crazy.
Okay.
Um,
do you think they're gonna do a reboot
or a sequel to
x Mokena?
I'd heard they were going to.
Sure.
Why wouldn't.
I mean why wait man,
fucking made it better.
It was a really good movie,
made a bunch of money and it was
amazing.
They better.
Um,
I am worried about that.
I am worried and I'm also worried that
by the fact that guys like Elon Musk are
worried that when,
when someone like that worries and he
starts talking about it,
I'm like,
well,
who is paying attention to this?
I mean,
how many people are really at the
forefront?
And is it possible to pull that back?
Because I'm aware of what the United
States is up to in terms of like what
gets printed to the news.
Obviously I'm not really aware,
but when you get further than that,
like China,
Russia,
like we don't,
we have no idea what they're doing.
Yeah.
And they must be doing this type of
thing.
They must be.
And if you don't,
they will.
Yeah.
It's one of those things,
something they don't need this huge,
a physical infrastructure,
like they don't need a big military or
anything to do cyber warfare with Ai.
Fuck.
So they could be developing all this
artificial intelligence to do things
like a infiltrate everybody's social
media and make them vote for the
difference
guy or just infiltrate all our power
stations and they shut them all down.
That's one of the real problems that I
have today with,
um,
the conversations regarding politics
regarding whether or not Russia hacked
the election is because people are so
concerned with painting out their party
to be innocent and the other party to be
guilty and describing all the different
things that the Russians did and the
interference and all of the,
you know,
the subterfuge it's being used that
were,
I think we're missing out on this idea
that you can electronically affect the
way people think about things if you
have enough resources to attack an idea
with propaganda through bots and this is
something that you see all the time.
Yeah.
A lot of the stuff that Russia did was
posted in closed groups on facebook.
So it's something that you really
wouldn't be able to see happening.
Like if you have to be a part of the
group.
Those traits.
Yeah.
They joined these groups,
uh,
and they,
they have not bought some birch,
but like,
you know,
they had these sweatshops where all
these people are typing away doing all
kinds of stuff,
pushing out these stories and they go
into these closed groups because it's
harder for people to figure out what's
going on if you're in a closed group and
they post all this stuff,
all these,
you know,
whatever,
Anti Hillary memes or whatever pro
Donald Trump like pro Bernie to push a
certain narrative.
One of them where the guy got busted
because he accidentally hat on is
location and showed that he was in
Russia and uh,
you know,
who's
some guy with a make Hashtag Maga,
an American flag and his avatar and the
whole deal.
Yeah.
It's going
to be really hard to figure out exactly
what happened.
That it's gonna be even harder in the
future though because we will be
covering the tracks a lot better.
The learning.
Yes,
what works,
but it's really hard to figure out
what's real and what's not real right
now.
Yeah.
You don't remember wag the dog.
What was that like 20 years ago and that
movie,
they described the possibility of faking
these conflicts and having this fake
video and having movie directors film
everything and that would influence the
way people thought about world conflicts
and now we're getting to a stage where
that technology is a lot more,
a little more realistic,
faking videos.
You were pretty close.
There are things where you can take
audio now and just basically sample
audio and create anything that person
might say.
Yeah,
that was a radiolab podcast where they
did it and it's still a little crude,
but like most things,
I mean you go back to the very first
oculus rift,
which was only a few years ago and it
was a pixilated and clunky looking,
but if you look at the htc vive now
they're virtual reality's pretty
spectacular.
You could still tell that it's not real,
but man,
the experience is so much more
immersive.
Yeah.
I remember reading a book back in the
nineties.
I think it's less than zero by Brett
Easton.
Ellis.
Yeah,
and this is seen in that way.
They,
they map somebodies face onto like a
pulling,
pulling back to a,
and at the time I thought that was the
most ridiculously stupid thing I've ever
heard of because they would never
possibly work and there's no way of
getting that degree of accuracy and now
I've got an app in my iphone that
actually does it to a reasonable degree
where it's quite hard sometimes to see
what's going on.
There's this thing called um,
mugged life,
which is just a toy app where you take a
picture of yourself and instantly like
mapsys onto a three d face and you can
do all these expressions and you can say
these things.
He can.
He has these like meme generators and
it's basically,
it's,
it's that type of thing,
which I thought was ridiculous.
Speculation like 20 years ago.
But now it's come to pass.
While there is an article that I tweeted
today about Gal Godot,
who is the woman from wonder woman,
they've take,
they use an algorithm and they tape her
face onto a porn video.
Yeah.
So they have her doing porn and it looks
just like her.
You can kind of tell a little bit that
it's not her,
but not much.
It's enough where you like,
Whoa,
they're going to get really good at this
and then there'll be able to have you
doing anything.
You could be a murderer,
they can have you outside murdering
people and they put that in the news and
then by the time they retract it,
you know,
and they say,
I'll make west wasn't really out there.
Just gunning people down.
It was someone else.
Your neighbors don't trust you anymore.
You have to move.
The damage is done,
you know,
and that's not,
not that I support like the fucking
hysterics and the craziness that trump
tweets and all the different shit that
he tweets,
but occasionally they get things wrong
and they make stories about him.
Like,
like the CNN,
Russia story where they had a fire.
Those three.
Yeah.
Well when they,
after they had fired those reporters who
had made these erroneous connections and
had this like a flaw written piece,
they fired them.
But the story has already been written
like this is,
I guess there's a rush to get things out
there and they're trying very hard,
but you've got to be very careful
because once something's out there,
that initial thing of being out there is
so much more powerful than any
retraction.
Yeah.
It's really hard to get retractions out
because the original thing just goes so
much more than the retraction.
Especially if it's crazy.
Really more thing going on right now.
The election today,
there's a thing where they said that his
signature was fake because the ink on
the image was like black on one side and
blue on the other side.
So they said,
oh,
this must have been faked because this
half of the Roy is black and the more
blue.
So I was looking into that and I did
some experiments where I did a signature
and then held it at an angle and took
photos of it.
And I found out that this,
this type of chromatic aberration from
the camera,
which just does that with ink and it's
very easy to duplicate and you can show
that this was actually what was going on
in his image,
and then you can look at other images of
the signature from different angles
which show that it's all black.
So those,
there's one image on CNN that she had
this blue and black ink.
And uh,
then I figured out that it was just this
trick of the camera,
but even though it's been debunked and
explained this,
people are still spreading the exact
same thing around.
So that's not real.
And that can be a problem.
It could swing the election.
Yeah.
And it's time limited,
that type of thing.
Like,
you know,
it's done today,
after today.
It doesn't really matter.
There was also something about him
writing something in someone's yearbook.
Yeah.
That was the book thing was the,
the thing was they said that the woman
had forged the entry to the yearbook,
but that's not the case.
What she had done was written the date
of the note,
the old hickory house.
Yes,
but she didn't,
didn't forge the actual words she is,
but that's a.
that's a problem.
The problem is that she did do it and
she didn't say she did it.
There's so many people want that to be
true,
that it was forged.
That if you can take something that's
like slightly problematic,
like her,
like not saying that she actually added
this annotation afterwards and then you
can say that,
that she admitted to it being forged,
which is basically a lie,
but it,
it will stick for long enough.
It doesn't really matter that it's a lie
because you know,
in,
you know,
by the end of the day today he doesn't
really matter at all.
So only had to do was get this story out
there.
You had enough stuff in it to make it
seem vaguely plausible to people who
wanted to believe that she,
she fortunate.
Did she forged the date and did she try
to say that that date was
written by him?
She,
I didn't note underneath it had the
date,
but he had also written on the date
above.
He wrote like,
you know,
to a sweeter,
more darling girl,
I could never say merry Christmas,
Roy Moore,
77 and then underneath she addressed and
uh,
old hickory house,
1977.
And did she try to claim that he had
written that originally?
It seemed like she was saying that he'd
written the whole thing.
Uh,
uh,
it's.
And she,
she read out the inscription and she
said,
Roy Moore wrote this in my book,
Blah,
blah,
blah.
And she'd read the,
the annotation at the end of the
annotation at the end.
Recent?
Yeah.
Nothing.
I think she said she wrote it like
afterwards,
like you have to shoe.
Oh,
the same day.
so how the fuck achieving remember how
do you remember what you wrote down in
1977 at that handwriting is a bit
different between them.
So it was fairly obvious that it wasn't
the same,
the same handwriting from stuff that's
like her today.
Trying to frame him,
that seems more like she was just
documenting it at the time.
And for golf,
anything,
it makes it more realistic.
So if she was going to forge it,
she would afford to.
The whole thing was she's talking about
something for 40 years ago.
Like,
ah,
yeah,
that's this,
this whole thing of trying to,
like someone's saying that this
definitely happened 40 years ago is to
me,
so bonkers to the hell could you,
and this is a real problem with the
news,
you know,
like one of the Al Franken accusers we
were talking about yesterday,
uh,
claim that Al had grabbed her,
her waist and squoze her fat and some
sort of way when she's talking about
something 10 years ago.
Like,
you absolutely remember what happened in
something so inconsequential 10 years
ago.
That seems insane to me.
Now you add 30 years onto that and I'm
just calling bullshit.
Yeah.
The,
you can't really remember the level of
detail that a lot.
I mean,
even if you would have to be something
really significant,
but even then you knew about creative
memories.
Yeah.
People's memories change over time.
Yes.
A lot of people a claim,
they remember where they were when they
heard about the space shuttle blowing up
the first one.
Yeah.
The people have done extensive research
into that like tracking people's stories
over like a decade or so,
and they found that a significant
percentage of people change the store is
10 years later,
I'm sure asked about why they were so
like for something like harassment or
something like that.
It's entirely possible that the story
could change.
Doesn't mean that it's false.
It's just possible that it could change,
but they're there conveniently
forgetting or ignoring that human
memories insanely flawed and malleable
and I think part of why we have statute
of limitations because like things like
eyewitness testimony essentially
degrades over time.
That's one of the things that I'm really
hoping is going to be cured with
technology.
I'm hoping we're going to give up our
bullshit
biological memory for a fat SD card.
They stick in the back of your head.
Just pop that sucker in there and look
and you'll have all of your memories
entirely accurate.
Like a.
That was a black mirror episode says
motherfuckers are on top of everything.
They know everything,
but I really think that that's entirely
possible in the future that there's
going to be some way we have a neural
interface with some sort of recording
device.
It's far more accurate and that we'll
all agree to it.
We'll all agree to.
It's just like photographs,
like if Jamie is standing next to you
and I say Jamie and Mick West,
we're in the room together and take a
picture.
It used to be that I could say,
well that's definite because I have this
photo,
but now with photoshop and video editing
tools,
so even then,
so what am I talking about?
Because even in your memory,
these are going to go create our visual
intelligence,
brightening,
creating memories for you.
Well there wasn't that like a total
recall,
right?
It wasn't that part of the idea of total
recall.
They could put you put like fake
memories in your brain and have you have
fake experiences.
There's a lot of experiences that I had
that award gigantic to me like all of my
years of martial arts competition.
If you had asked me to like accurately
depict some of the most significant
memories of my life from age 16 to 21,
like all those martial arts fights that
I had,
I wouldn't even be able to touch it.
I have,
I've zero.
I've scrapped.
I've like flashes.
Yeah.
I was starting to figure out all this
stuff.
I didn't never soft when I was working
on Sandy Hook.
Like I just got interviewed for the,
doing a documentary about the making
well about the history of Neversoft and
Tony Hawk and the guy's interviewing me
and I'm like,
I kind of remember it was like somebody
is like 20 years ago,
but it's that type of thing that I
thought I would never forget that
because it was such a significant part
of my life,
but it's just kind of dropping away over
the years.
Anything that happens a lot with the,
you know,
people are looking back on nine slash 11
and going by the memories of what
happened that day and it changes your
memory changes.
Yeah,
I will,
I will.
There's a few things that I remember
because there like some significance to
it.
Like I remember the space shuttle thing
because I was over at an ex girlfriend's
house and it was one of the few times
that we saw each other before we had
completely stopped seeing each other,
like we had kind of broken up and then I
drove out to her house to visit her and
then while I was over at house,
we saw the launch.
We were like,
Holy Shit,
we,
we actually saw the
play of it blowing up and were like,
Whoa,
like this is fucked.
See some people say that replay and then
they remember that to seeing the actual
event,
so why?
And so they think they saw right live.
So that becomes a memory.
I'm pretty,
pretty good at that.
I'm pretty.
I'm pretty good at going over my
memories to make sure that I'm thinking,
yeah,
you think maybe you're not.
Maybe you shouldn't go back and check
some of these memories of Tom,
Tom and your ex girlfriend and asked her
if that really happened.
I remember very clearly where I was when
Sam Kennison died.
I remember definitely where I was when
nine slash 11 happened.
Yeah,
because I got some calls from friends
and they woke me up.
My phone kept ringing and I remember
that because I remember being in my
house.
I remember turning on the TV.
That's 100 percent.
I was driving to work.
I was on the floor of five,
so I remember that.
It seems to be very solidly,
but seems there are details around that.
Like I remember I went to,
I went to Taco bell on the way to get
some food because I thought it might be
a long day now as the.
How much is enough to get dental care.
Remember now I went to a gas station.
I think I went to Taco Bell.
Dang.
Now I'm starting to forget what happened
on nine slash 11.
I remember the day
because I spent it with uh,
Eddie and Joey Diaz and a couple other
friends of mine.
We went to the,
went to a burrito joint on sunset in
Hollywood and we were just talking about
how there's no flights like look,
because we'd heard that the flight tend
to like,
look man,
you see a plane.
This guy's weird.
It felt weird.
We felt like we're stuck in California.
Whereas the freedom of air travels,
it's something that if you don't fly a
lot you don't think about.
But if you,
if you really do,
if they pull it away,
there's no more air travel.
Like what?
We're stuck here,
how long it take to drive to Colorado to
that 16 hours and shit.
Like you don't think about it going back
in time in a way.
Different Times.
Yeah.
Well at least you have cars say the
train.
Yeah.
So is there anything else that we,
um,
we might disagree on?
Hm,
let me disagree with.
I know what,
uh,
I think we,
I think we agree on the flat earth
stuff.
Uh,
no.
You think the earth is round,
right?
What about a changed my tune.
What about did long Matt Delong?
The,
the guy who from blink one eight,
two.
Oh Tom.
Tom,
Tom Delonge.
Oh,
he's out of his fucking mind,
right man.
People's bastard.
Yeah.
He's um,
he's got some weird shit going on and
since that podcast,
a bunch of people have pointed out to me
that he is essentially,
they are selling stock in a competence.
Yeah.
The suddenly stuck and also he gets a
guarantee pay out.
Yeah.
Oh,
like I think $100,000
a year or something like that.
Well,
whatever it goes,
how much money they take in what they
make.
If you get enough rubes to keep donating
money to this.
It mean he keeps saying stay tuned.
Things are gonna happen.
And I said there's gonna be some videos
released.
Yeah,
like nearly a month ago now.
I think dude,
when he was on the podcast,
he played some videos for us that were
like absolutely ufos.
And I almost pissed my pants laughing.
They were so bad.
It was so bad.
One of them was so fucking bad.
I was like,
dude,
if that was in a movie I would want my
money back.
I'd be angry.
So like,
what do you mean easy?
A crazy guy,
or is he a smart guy who was making
money?
I do not know.
I think it must.
It must like this,
this ufo stuff he loves,
so I stay saying I'm making money,
but the conversation I look,
there's two ways to approach this and I
tried to be district.
I tried to be respectful because I'm the
host and he agreed to come here and he
wanted to talk about this so I'll try to
be respectful and let this guy talk and
what he was saying to me was so
ridiculous.
I was like,
I don't even have to challenge him on
this because it's so obviously
ridiculous.
Everyone is going to see that.
It's ridiculous.
I was wrong.
There was a lot of people that listened
to that podcast that I saw on twitter
that thought that what he was saying was
mind blowing and this is real.
Those are the people that are going to
donate.
He exactly right.
Now,
is there a problem with that?
Is there a problem with the Catholic
church because they're full of shit too.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
Catholic churches essentially a
moneymaking franchise and they don't
have to pay taxes.
At least he has to pay taxes.
I mean,
is there a.
is there a problem with conning rubes
out of money?
There's loads of kickstarter's a
technology,
things that just could never work like
those days,
like clearer holograms.
They say you'll get to play video games
on the table in front of you.
Oh yeah.
There's a go fund me's for people that
don't have illnesses that.
Yeah,
there's like one way that they had a
water bottle,
it would magically take water out of the
uh,
saw that one.
Yeah.
But it doesn't actually work.
It would take like three days to fill
the bottle.
If you were in a rain forest anyway,
require like a solar panel list,
like this big,
it's just easy to bring,
bring your in.
But they raised like $2,000,000.
And what do they have to do with that
money?
They're allowed to keep it.
They can keep it.
If they went to the kickstarter.
Kickstarter has this open thing where
you're developing a prototype so it
doesn't actually have to work.
Wow.
So what happens with that?
So all those people is this it us?
Yeah,
and I think they might've like Gogo
though.
They might've been on a couple of
different platforms and one of them is
more a more relaxed than the other in
terms of what it will allow.
Like one of them now you could have a
working prototype.
The self filling water bottle.
Yeah.
It's bullshit.
Compulsively go created it.
Yeah.
A lot of these eastern European
scientists types who do things like
this.
So they made it look like this dude's
just driving around and then this sense
of pull it out of air and then he can
just pull it out of the tube and wow,
look,
I've got water all of a sudden.
Yeah.
It can't possibly work.
It,
it,
it uses a real technology,
like these little electrical things
actually cool things down and condense
things and it will actually condense a
little bit,
but hardly anything.
So we'd take a long ass time for to fill
was basically a dehumidifier.
I don't know if you have like a,
like a dehumidifier.
The,
the every humidifier.
Because California's drought,
he ever have a dehumidifier,
it will eventually fill up the container
of the dehumidifier,
but this is this thing powered by
plugging it into the wall and it's this
big machine and it still takes all day
to fill up the reservoir.
So they're saying like a little water
bottle this size with a little solar
panel and this little condensing thing
that's this big.
We'll fill it up in a few hours.
Well maybe it's like physically
impossible physical face technology
swapping thing like 20 years ago it was
impossible,
but 20 years from now they're playing
the long game.
We can water bottle,
you can improve computers,
but you can't really improve the laws of
physics.
You can only get so much water out of
the parcel parcel of uh,
so they would have to have some sort of
better mechanism for extracting it than
what they're doing.
Yeah.
There's,
I mean there's certainly a lot of scams
out there.
I don't know if that's what he's doing.
When I talked to people that knew him
from a long time ago,
he's been obsessed with Ufo is forever.
So his obsession seems to be legitimate.
However,
when I was talking to him about all the
events and I was like,
tell me what happened.
You gotta a guy contacted you.
While I can't say who I can't say,
I can't say what it was,
I can't tell you that we can't get into
that.
That's all bullshit.
When someone starts talking like that,
they're full of shit.
He,
he definitely seemed to be a combination
of deceptive and delusional.
Well,
the,
the slides that he used in the talk to
illustrate there was an event of some
Ufo buzzing a aircraft carrier and some
fighter jets.
We're going after it and they couldn't
find it and they put up some slides on
the screen there which looked like a
shiny silver penis flying around.
And it was actually something that type
of thing we do on metal bunks,
identify objects like that.
So we figured out what this was and it's
actually a,
a number one numerical helium balloon,
like the digit one.
Oh Wow.
Like someone's like from a party.
And I found like a bunch of other shots
of the same thing where you can see it
rotating and you can see it's fairly
clear.
It's this number one,
but it's on this,
um,
this,
uh,
conspiracy website.
They thought it was a Ufo.
So he got it off that.
And so this is a Ufo took the image,
kind of degraded a bit.
So you can't reach out to where it was.
It was quite hard for me to track it
down because he'd mess with it so much.
It was actually just this,
this helium balloon that was a white
shiny.
What's disturbing to me is that he's got
this business that claims to be some
sort of aerospace business and he's
involved in it with all these other
people.
It's weird because the guy who's running
that a can't remember his name for
fortune or something like that,
is like a real guy who worked at
Lockheed Martin or somewhere and the
skunkworks amy started doing adderall,
started getting crazy.
Know what he's talking about.
It makes no sense whatsoever.
He says,
our mission is to take what the science
division gives us and we'll turn that
science into flying craft.
Right.
But at the science division does.
It doesn't really.
Right.
They've got like a guy who's like one
guy who was interested in like shooting
a things with lasers to make them go
fast.
Yeah.
That was one of the weird things.
We're not just talking,
I'm just gonna have a real technology.
You can use a laser to power power of
craft,
but yeah,
that's not what they're talking about.
That talking about some kind of crap.
The wolves,
the very nature of time and space itself
to kind of ride rides a wave of a.
we're a wormhole or something like that.
Yeah,
and this guy thinks that it's plausible
and only have to do is kind of like try
really,
really hard.
If they put their heads together and
like this scientists who all this
science a lot and then these builders do
that really good building based on these
really good science they're going to
get.
Then they'll,
they'll get this flying craft Johnson's
nothing's going to happen.
It hasn't.
Having people donated some something
like $2,000,000
or something goofy like that.
How many fucking people have done that?
See if you can find that out to 2000.
90 two people have donated
$2,000,000.
Yeah.
Wow.
So that's a thousand dollars each.
That's a lie.
That seems wrong.
I know the numbers,
the numbers have changed frequently.
Well,
the numbers seemed really high in terms
of the amount of donations.
Like it's very odd.
You're going to get 2000 people to
donate a thousand dollars each.
That doesn't seem right.
It could be a few very large donors that
is somehow convinced to donate via this.
There are a lot of really fucking crazy
old people that believe in this shit and
they might have a ton of money.
What do you mean?
What's that red line meant to represent?
Kind of looks like they're flying right
about the stars.
Academy of Arts and science.
That's what kills me.
What kind of arts?
What are you doing?
Fingerprint.
I'm always tracking those numbers for
awhile and they were going up
proportionately.
If that's the correct word to say from
each other.
The one that number was going up while
the number,
the dollar number was sort of staying
the same,
so maybe he was calling these people if
you double your off,
getting a lot of people on the first
ship submitted Mo of 200 I think really
sound this bold,
bold print down the.
So some large donations.
It's amazing though to still pretty
large.
Donated $2,000,000
to this wacky ass fucking company.
Yeah,
and Ole.
All the company is required to do is pay
delong $100,000
a year for the next seven years or
something and that's it.
Really.
The crazy thing too is that they,
that he had been contacted by the
government because they knew that he
could go on shows like mine and talk
about this.
Then he would have a platform because
he's a rockstar.
I was like,
what?
This is like some.
Why didn't they stop him?
This is some bad movie shit.
Like this narrative is like a bad movie
is that people like say they didn't want
to talk to me on the phone because
they're afraid of the government
tracking them down and assassinating
them or whatever.
It's like I'm talking to you on
facebook.
Well,
yeah,
if I really was like this,
you know,
agents of the government,
it wouldn't be very hard to just say,
yeah,
get,
get rid of this guy.
That's a big one.
They like to pull on you because you
debunk things.
You're an agent of the government.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and it's really hard one to get around.
I think that the,
my approach there,
I was just to be as honest as possible
all the time,
so I always tell them exactly who I am.
Like that.
I made lots of money during the Tony
Hawk video games.
I'm just like British video game
programmer.
Basically my life story,
they don't buy it.
They don't buy in it pal.
They don't.
But yeah,
I think some of them it,
it helps telling them about the.
About Tony Hawk.
Yeah.
It's a lot of them actually are fans of
Tony Hall and that's funny actually.
Well,
it's,
it's one of those things where if you
don't want to believe you're not going
to,
you're gonna like that's a likely cover
story for a guy and then then they'll go
super deep.
Oh,
the government has infiltrated video
games in order to keep kids stupid.
They've created these games in order to
mess with the kids' minds.
And one reaction I get quite a bit is
the,
I am stupid.
You're stupid.
Yeah.
A lot of people will say that I am
really stupid.
Those people like who were in like,
you know,
the architects and engineers when nine
slash 11 truth type thing who think the
time really stupid and don't understand
physics at all.
And so that they say that,
but I'm not a government agent.
I'm just this really stupid dude who
doesn't understand what actually
happened in nine slash 11 useful idiot.
Right?
Yeah.
Uh,
and not just in the useful idiot in that
sense,
but a person who,
uh,
is just mistaken.
Right.
Is it just so then they can dismiss my
videos by laughing at them,
like I do lots of little videos where I
do things like demonstrate how something
buckles,
like a column buckling when you put a
load on it or you think things like
that,
just just physics videos and then they
just say,
yeah,
you're an idiot.
We don't need to look at this video.
So it's a way of getting around the
problem and a lot of other people say
that I'm so smart about chem trails and
things like that that I must be a
government agent because I know so much
about contrarian,
so I get both sides of and why they're
really smart government agent or I'm
just a stupid,
a useful idiot.
Well it's just them looking at you and
trying to find some way to dismiss what
you're saying,
but you,
you really get a kick out of debunking
shit.
I do span the backyard science stuff.
There was a thing I did recently where
A.
Yeah,
so the scientists were saying that the
bits falling off the world trade center,
we're leaving trails.
That must be fraud.
And the rocket motors that are pushing
them away from the World Trade Center.
So I said now he's probably just some
some dust on it and they say no,
I wouldn't do that.
He wouldn't live a long trail.
So I got a big sledgehammer and I piled
some some ashes on it from my fireplace.
And then I stood on top of a wall and I
was throwing this sledgehammer with a
big trailer.
Dust is coming from it for like half an
hour videoing myself doing it until I
got some of the,
some representative videos of it.
It's just fun to do.
It is kind of fun.
You know,
one of the ones that kept up
that I thought was the most ridiculous
thing about the flat earth was I read
this a couple of places where people are
talking about ships disappearing on the
horizon and then the ship disappeared.
But if you pulled out,
if you zoom in,
you can still see the ship.
Yeah.
And I was like,
well,
how come you can't see Mount Everest
motherfucker?
Why can't you look towards Japan?
Where's Mt Kilimanjaro?
Get up.
How come you can see the moon?
You could see the moon.
If you get a good telescope,
you could see the moon really clearly.
Take that telescope.
Don't point at the moon point across the
ocean.
Where's the mountains?
The atmosphere that the kind of advanced
special.
You know,
I was talking about how not architects
and engineers when nine slash 11 have to
do this really I'd punch thing now
because we've debunked the basic stuff
so they can move to this advanced stuff.
Same thing with the flat earth people.
Now they can.
You demonstrate how things actually do
go over the horizon and we're going to
do get obscured by the horizon and how
the sunsets and things like that and so
they come up with a complicated
explanation where there's this kind of
giant,
a refractive lens of atmosphere above
the earth,
which is bending all the light from the
sun in such a way that the earth appears
to be round even though he's actually
flat.
Don Don,
Don,
which kind of begs the question like,
how do they actually know it's round?
If it looks,
how do they know it's flat?
If it looks round right,
like yeah,
things are disappearing over the horizon
as if it looks round because of this
refraction thing,
but they think it's flat,
but if it looks round,
why are they thinking explant?
Well,
the thing that killed me was that you
could zoom in on it and that proved that
the,
that it wasn't actually disappearing
over the horizon.
I know a little bit about optics because
of my fascination with the outdoors.
I have a bunch of binoculars spotting
scopes,
various power,
and there's things you just cannot see
that.
Then you get a good spotting scope on
them.
So with the naked eye,
like there's things you can't see with
the naked eye,
you would swear they do not exist.
They're not there,
but then you get a great spotting scope
on them and you could see him miles away
and that's the thing with ships.
You've got a large ship.
It goes far enough away.
You can't see it anymore and you'll be
convinced that it's disappeared over the
horizon when in fact it's only probably
a couple of inches lower on the horizon.
As far as like the curve of the earth,
but to the naked eye,
it's invisible because so when they zoom
in on it,
they're convinced that Aha,
there is no curvature of the earth.
See,
this looked like it went over the
horizon,
but it's an optical illusion.
Yeah,
and the thing is that I've been sharing
this so many times because this actually
happened.
It was this so many videos now on
youtube that actually demonstrate this
thing like this time lapses of ships
going over the horizon,
like zoomed in all the way with that p
900 cameras.
We do like an 83 times zoom as big as
you can go.
Yep.
It's been demonstrated.
They just ignore her.
They say they ignore it because it's not
in their same q.
If you look at the play in the flat
earth video,
all the cue to the right is like flat
earth expose.
Some of those get hundreds of thousands
of views.
This is one guy,
Dr Zack,
who's a foreign guy who does the.
He does these,
the these flutters videos and they're
all mathematically sharing things in
autocad with drawn lines and stuff and
he gets like 400,000
views.
It's amazing.
It's bizarre.
Well,
it's just amazing that so many people
get get into this and they buy into it.
Do you see that one where that young man
took a spirit ruler,
spirit level on an airplane is flying
around in airplanes and was convinced
Darrell Martin is the guy's name.
He lives in a van.
It doesn't.
Yeah.
He has a bunch of videos on van life.
He's a cool guy.
He's a very nice guy,
but he's got this weird idea about
aflutter.
It's so.
I've had a few youtube battles with him
where he puts up something about how the
moon is cooling things and he has this
thermometer thing showing that the moon
is actually making things cold.
Then I put up a videos explaining why,
you know,
it's just a reflection because he's an
infrared.
Thermometers don't work that way and
then he puts another thing like debunk
this mic west.
Like I gave up at that point.
Wasn't a separate short battle.
Well,
the weird thing is that they see all
these other planets is round,
but they decided that the earth is flat,
that it's some sort of a flat disk.
Yeah.
The thing is that different.
Yes.
They are these tiny little bowls that
are like two miles wide or something and
they think the earth is really close to
the sun.
Yeah,
I think it's about 4,000
miles away.
Four miles away.
Oh,
you fucking idiots.
They think the distance to the sun.
Various depending on the Observer.
Observer.
Dependent.
Oh,
like where you are.
It's only four miles away.
Imagine if,
if you drive away,
just get super small,
like what the fuck?
Yeah.
I mean it makes no sense.
It's so ridiculous,
but it's just,
to me it's such a strange thing to
concentrate on that this is like their
identity is wholly invested in improving
this thing to be some sort of a massive
conspiracy.
Yeah,
very,
very strange.
It's love it.
You love it.
They love it.
You love debunking.
That's the thing.
It's like it's,
it's a rabbit hole for debunkers is a
flyer that you just get sucked into it.
It's one of the best ones because it's
so silly.
It is.
There's no.
Here's the thing that people send me.
People like,
I don't know if they're trolling me or
if they're serious,
they'll send me a picture of a glacier
and they'll go,
there's your fucking your ice wall.
Yeah.
They show you the real shelf or
something like that.
Like an actual ice shelf on Toptica.
Yeah.
You can look up the video,
the picture and see what it actually is.
The government,
the government is guarding the,
the ice wall
all around.
So you can't get near it.
Take pictures of it.
Yeah.
That's the thing.
Like the southern hemisphere is a huge
problem for the,
uh,
for the flood of authors because you
can,
you can have somebody standing on light
the south of South America.
So I went to in Australia and they both
looking south,
which on a desk will be away looking
completely different directions.
And they're both actually.
Yeah,
because they're both fairly close to
each other really.
They're looking at the same stars in the
sky.
Yeah,
and there's this,
even though they're really complicated
explanations for the flush of.
Don't explain that.
One of the.
The hot irrefutable proofs of a round a
constantly changing their story based on
what gets debunked.
Like the big one that do bay was saying
forever,
every photograph of earth from space is
a composite.
Well that's not true.
They have full scale.
Full image,
high resolution photographs from the
[inaudible] eight.
Yeah.
Those are fake.
Then they decided that those are fake.
So at first it was those,
they're composites,
which there was some composites from
lower side lights and then blue marble
thing.
That's how that goes.
Stuff.
It is the famous issue of famous image
of the Blue Mobile,
which is a NASA very high resolution
image that they did back in the nineties
from composites because they went to to
get something which had all of the
landmass without any clouds on.
Right.
So they have to take loads and loads of
pitches and just take the bits that had
no clouds on and then stitch them all
together and then they created this
thing and then they did a separate one
that had just the clouds and then they
can put them together and move them
around and stuff.
How many different satellites are taking
full earth images?
Probably around 30 or 40.
How many of those are run by government?
Chills.
A.
They're all run by government.
Actually not all run by well are eight
is the Japanese one was a Russian one,
which is about the same.
Especially to Russian wounds.
There's a European one,
meteo sat and the American high
resolution one just went up a few months
ago.
It's offline at the moment because the
moving it from one side of the United
States to the other.
Damn.
They moving it.
How long does that take?
A few days.
Jesus now?
Yeah.
How the fuck do they do that?
Little little jets.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
You've seen a gravity.
Yeah.
That's how things move around and get
things moving in a direction and then
sending them the anchor it in that spot.
That's something that confuses people is
how to rockets work in space.
They think that because there's no
atmosphere in space,
there's nothing to push against.
Right?
So how does a rocket actually work in
space?
Or does it?
It's action and reaction.
If you throw something in this
direction,
you will move in the opposite direction.
I say if you sit in your chair,
take a big bowling ball or something,
throw it in that direction really fast,
you'll move back a bit.
So if you get like a,
an air,
a hose and you pointed us in that
direction and you're standing on ice or
something,
you will move in the opposite direction.
It doesn't matter if there's a.
If you throw something that way,
that has to be her reaction in the
opposite direction.
Okay,
that makes sense.
Um,
a lot of those guys don't even believe
in satellites.
Yeah.
They don't have to.
Because how could they?
They think that they think that signals
are bounced off the ionosphere.
There's no satellite.
Yeah.
But you can,
you can see this adult lives.
Yeah,
you can see,
you can see the space station,
you can see it fly overhead and I get
emails whenever it is gonna fly overhead
and I go out and have a look and you can
see I've taken pictures of it.
You can see the solar panels and the
photographs that I've taken.
Wow.
And it always appears exactly where
necessarily it's going to appear
anywhere in the world.
That's the other problem with these
people that don't believe in satellites.
Is that,
how are we tracking the weather then?
How do we know exactly when the
hurricane's coming in weather balloons?
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's my concern about all this in
particular,
like the flatter stuff is young kids
wasting their time on stupid shit when
the world is filled with massive real
mysteries and incredibly fascinating
things you should be diving in and
learning about.
I think there's a great opportunity for
teaching kids with things like flatter
you can do real experiments to determine
that the earth is not flat.
Maybe even more importantly,
teaching them about traps.
Thinking trap.
Yes.
The mind can allow you to go down.
You can teach them how to debunk.
Say this guy is saying that ships should
reappear when we zoom in,
how do we test this and then they can
get out and tested it.
Yeah,
well that that was.
That one was so stunningly stupid to me
and then I don't even want to go into
the flat earth thing anymore,
but it's the thinking behind it.
That's the problem.
The thinking that every single airline
pilot,
everyone involved in commercial
shipping,
everyone involved in aerospace.
Everyone who makes satellites,
everyone,
all those people are lying.
Every cartographer,
everyone,
all the mapmakers,
everyone.
They're all full of shit.
Everyone is agreed to not tell everyone
else about the ice wall.
If the earth was flat and there was an
ice wall,
scientists with detail it and they would
explain why the earth was flat and they
would show you a working model of the
earth being flat and that's what they
would teach in school.
There would be no.
There's no benefit whatsoever to
describing the earth in a shape that it
doesn't exist in.
Andy will be obvious that the earth was
flat because you can be able to do like
really simple tests yourself.
You see boats not going over the
horizon.
It's just so disturbing.
He would say the sun gets smaller as it
gets further away.
The Sun stays exactly the same size
throughout the day.
Sunrise,
noon,
sunset
at the same size of the moon does the
same thing.
Why does the moon look so much bigger
though?
When it's on the horizon with obstacle
of the optical illusion?
What is it is a perspective issue like
just the way your brain works.
If you take photographs of it like on
the horizon and then another photograph
of it when it's right up there and
compare them side by side,
they be the same.
Same zoom settings is exactly the same,
but it's interesting because it really
does look larger when it gets lower.
It's purely psychological.
The harvest moon,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
what is the August man?
Not that big old red moon or something
as the blood moon eclipse at the beaver
moon to beaver moon that you would take
one didn't know about a beaver moon
until they said it was the super moon,
which is when the moon is just very
close to you.
What is the Super Moon?
How much closer is a superman?
It's not much closer.
Really.
The eight actually only gets about eight
percent bigger than it.
Smallest is actually a very hard to see
that.
It's actually any big ap put them side
by side.
That's a lot though.
But people and yeah,
you see these news stories about
superbowl and go look at the super moon
tonight when it's,
uh,
it's not that much difference.
Oh.
Oh Wow.
That looks a little bit different.
But that's the very smallest movement
and the very largest moon most of the
time it's going to be somewhere in
between that.
So you're not really going to notice the
difference.
All right.
Then,
anything else we should cover before we
wrap this up?
Let me look at my list.
I have to write lists because my memory
is so bad.
Now.
I've offloaded everything like,
you know,
you're a standup comedians that you
could have mail to memorize all this
stuff.
Well,
not only that,
I have to memorize fights to UFC
information in my head and I have comedy
information in my head,
but if you asked me to do my act that I
did from last year like that,
I filmed for my netflix special.
I wouldn't be able to
do it.
Yeah.
Looking at my list and we've kind of
covered most of the things that are on
here.
We could go over some like nine slash 11
crap if you wanted to,
but I'm tired of it.
That's the thing about it.
At this stage of my life,
it's,
it seems when there's so many incredible
things to pay attention to that a real,
you know,
this is what I feel like about all this
stuff where people are looking into
conspiracies,
that they're just nonsense.
It's like you're chasing,
they're chasing their tail.
They're trying to confirm something
where there's so much evidence that it's
not real,
that it just,
it really bothers me.
It drives me nuts and I just don't
understand it and I don't,
I just,
I wish that it wasn't a problem.
I wish it wasn't an issue,
you know,
and it is and it's one of the reasons
why I continue to talk about these
things and I really want to shine as
much light on them as possible so that
there's,
there's a real pattern that you could
fall into and you can waste a tremendous
amount of time in your life if you start
looking at things incorrectly and flat
earth me is the best
example of it.
It's the best example because it's so
stupid.
I mean it's so utterly preposterous that
everyone is lying and that there are no
images at all of this flatter,
but yet this one guy or a couple of guys
and I had heard that it started out as
a,
as a troll on four Chan,
is that they had started doing this like
way back in,
you know,
like it could have been flooded I think
goes back to the 18th,
but the people would like reignited it
either way.
Just using that as a shit posting was we
talked about last time shit posting that
people have always believed in the
flood.
Uh,
yeah.
Let's wrap it up West.
I'm so [inaudible] dot com.
If anybody wants to go to [inaudible]
dot org,
my upcoming book escaping the rabbit
hole.
What is that coming out next September.
But have you finished it?
Have you done?
Nearly done?
Yeah,
nearly done.
Okay.
Excellent.
Alright.
Midwest,
everybody.
We'll be back tomorrow with UFC
heavyweight champion.
Steep Emile chick.
See.